all right the uh retirement system first
on our list
and that's on page 181 for those looking
problem
s
here with me today is
for those who have seen any
International Community
oh is your mic on yes there you go
we while we still have some challenges
in front of us we are pleased with the
Positive progress we have made and the
significant operational improvements
which have been implemented over the
past decade
the nhrs board and staff are committed
to promoting the stability and stability
of the sustainability and stability of
the retirement system
nhrs has over 48 500 members and 42 000
retirees and beneficiaries it is managed
by 13 trustees and investment oversight
is provided by an independent investment
committee consisting of six members
as fiduciaries they are obligated to act
solely in the interests of the system's
members and beneficiaries
with the exception of the state
treasurer who serves ex-officio trustees
and investment committee members are
appointed through the governor and
Council and serve three-year terms
the handout we prepare today provides
highlights initiatives and strategic
challenges impacting nhrs as well as
updates on current and recent
legislative activity and an overview of
our statutory administrative budget
which I would like to point out to you
is funded solely by the retirement
system it is does the monies do not come
from the general fund
the statutory administrative budget
encompasses all internal non-investment
related Administration costs including
I.T costs at full value
pursuant to statute the retirement
system sport of trustee reviews and
approves the statutory administrative
budget biennially
our statutory administrative operating
budget for fiscal year 23 is 12.2
million dollars and our proposed budgets
for the next two years are slightly
higher at 13 million in fiscal year 24
and 13.6 million in fiscal year 25.
based on fully Staffing all authorized
positions and complete implementation of
the pension system software upgrade
as you well know the New Hampshire
retirement system is not an executive
branch agency but is a statutorily
created pension trust although its
expenses flow through the state those
costs are reimbursed from the retirement
trust which is in turn funded by
contributions from employers and members
and investment returns
the budget which is before you today has
been fully vetted and adopted by our
Board of Trustees
before I go into greater detail on the
operations of the retirement system I'd
like to share these key facts about nhrs
nhrs provides a modest pension benefit
the average annual pension is just over
twenty one thousand eight hundred
dollars
nearly two-thirds of our forty two
thousand pension recipients receive less
than twenty five thousand dollars per
year
and HRS benefits are funded by member
contributions employer contributions and
investment returns
nhrs Investments have achieved an
average annual net return of 8.5 percent
over the last 10 years
the benefits that nhrs pays help support
New Hampshire's economy
in the last fiscal year nhrs paid out
more than 900 million in pensions and 45
million dollars in medical subsidy
benefits
just under 80 percent of retirees live
here in New Hampshire and spend their
money here
according to research released last year
bought the National Institute on
retirement system on retirement security
retired retiree expenditures stemming
from state and local pension benefits in
FY 2018
supported
8495 jobs in New Hampshire
there is a plan in place to pay to play
Down pay down the nhrs unfunded
liability
as everyone knows nhrs has a significant
unfunded Actuarial accrued liability
There are 16 years remaining on the
payoff of the original unfunded
liability which existed in 2007.
subsequent gains and losses occurring
after June 30 2017 are being amortized
over periods of no more than 20 years
on average roughly 80 percent of the
employer contribution rate for state
employees goes toward paying off the
unfunded liability
the employer contribution rates for the
four membership classifications employee
teacher police and fire will decrease in
fiscal year 24-25
the rate decreases primarily the result
of strong investment performance over
the five-year period ending June 30 2021
and those decreases in employer
contributions range from 3.75 percent to
8 percent
the trustees continue to strengthen the
plan by adopting revised Actuarial
assumptions recommended by the system's
actuaries
Actuarial assumptions were last revised
following a recent experience study for
the period 2016 through through 2019 and
including a reduction in the assumed
rate of return from 7.25 percent to 6.75
percent
because of its strong constitutional and
statutory Foundation nhrs is on the path
to full funding the retirement system is
making good progress on paying down its
unfunded liability
slow steady increase decrease in the
liability is projected in the coming
decades with a corresponding increase in
the funded ratio which is increased to
65.6 percent in fiscal year 2022 and
I'll take a couple of minutes to review
the highlights document and then talk
about our goals and objectives and this
is the the budget overview document from
the highlights I'm just going to share
some of the key ones we remain on
schedule with our multi-year project to
upgrade our core pension application
from the 22 year old version to the more
current version and the project is now
73 percent complete
foreign
we have implemented the seven bills that
were enacted in 2022 related to member
benefits that required significant
database modifications as well as
training for our staff and our members
our funded ratio as I mentioned earlier
increased to 65.6 percent as of June 30
2022 and as you can see from the chart
below it's on it's trending favorably
although we did receive a negative
investment return
for fiscal year 2022 our performance
relative to our peers was still very
good and I think everyone can
acknowledge there were a lot of unique
factors in the most in the most recent
year that caused the depressed markets
internationally
we issued our June 30 22 financial
statements with an unmodified or clean
opinion
and we'll be doing an Actuarial
experience study in 2024 for the
four-year period ending June 30 2023
this study will further the process of
assuring that the funding of the system
is in alignment with anticipated costs
for providing benefits and will also
ensure that all the assumptions that
underlie our Actuarial valuation are
accurate
so far this year it's been a busy year
in the session 21 bills related to nhrs
have been introduced this session in
passage of any legislation related to
benefit eligibility or calculations this
year will delay the implementation of
our pension database upgrade and add to
our project's costs
the governor at nhrs's request has
included a forty thousand dollar
appropriation in House Bill 2 to provide
long-term funding for a closed
non-pension Legacy benefit administered
by the retirement system for two widows
of coal fire fighters killed in the line
of duty so those were the key highlights
that I wanted to share with you and I
will now turn the floor over to Marie
Mullen our Director of Finance to walk
you through our budget
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee
um for the Retirement Systems budget
we've provided a chart here that shows
our actual expenditures over the the
budget and um we left off the actual
expenditures I apologize for that but in
2022 our budget was 12.3 million our
actuals were 10.2 million so due to
vacancies and some other efficiencies we
were able to spend less than our budget
um so you can see over the years we've
tried to maintain a real a study budget
not we have a fiduciary responsibility
so we we try to be very efficient in
what we're doing and how we provide
services to the members and retirees
if you turn to the last page
this is our administrative budget as
presented during the agency phase and
then as the governor has presented in
his budget
um there was only one minor change
between our submission and the
governor's budget and that was in the
retiree Health Care line number 12 in in
our chart here there was a slight
reduction in the retiree health care
costs that were provided
um for our salaries and benefits we are
we did see an increase over the FY 23
adjusted authorized and that's related
to
um the negotiated increases we have a
separate Union from the the state so our
um negotiated increases were done we
have a three-year contract prior to us
submitting the budget
so we had a 4.7
4.75 salary increase in 24 and a 4.5
percent increase in fiscal year 25.
um our technology and software Hardware
lines you can see we we have an increase
there that is due to the increased risk
related to cyber security we are trying
to shore up our our cyber security and
also we have a significant server
replacement coming up in in fiscal year
25 that we need to fund as well
and then one of the the larger lines on
here is related to our pension gold
project that executive director Jan has
mentioned before
the cost there we anticipate going live
in fiscal year 24 there will be some
residual enhancements and then ongoing
maintenance costs for that so we have
included the the pension software the
cost for that for the upgrade the
maintenance in our budget for 24 and 25
there
so I'll I'll upon that I'll leave it
open to any questions for the members of
the committee
represent McGuire followed by
representative Griffin uh thank you Mr
chairman
um just basically do you have roughly a
hundred employees is that my guess 77 77
okay and and how many are actual and how
many
um are authorized
uh all of ours are authorized
no no you said you were missing some
that's why you didn't spend as much
well it's it's just turnover I should
say it's turnover during the year so you
have a few months where you're until you
bring someone in so you have savings
right you're not spending the salaries
and benefits while you have a vacancy
but all of ours are authorized we have
two vacancies currently right now we
we're constantly filling those
um so it's very minor but yeah very
minor
may ask something else yeah thank you so
um this hardware and software line four
of the little handout says
um the we're going to spend
um 1.1 1.2 million per year but in the
budget itself if you look at a line page
181 line 37 and 38. that's more like 200
and 2.8 2.9 kind of number yeah we've
broken that out so we have the the
technology and software Hardware related
to our ongoing like operations and
maintenance and then we broke out some
of that hardware and software into the
pension gold that what is specific to
that project so that's why you don't see
all of it in line four a large portion
of that is related to the the pension
gold software upgrade so we've included
it in line 18 in our in our schedule
sure so this and so our schedule in
online 18 also includes the salaries and
benefits and and other miscellaneous
costs related to that project
oh I see so that's why I knew that the
sum is either too big or too little
right yeah okay but overall the total
matches the the total budget now is this
project something that's going to end so
we would expect line 18 to to disappear
at some point there will still be
ongoing maintenance and warranty costs
related to it but the the Consulting and
some of the the initial costs will will
reduce it won't be at this level going
into the future but currently while
we're in the middle of we have the
Consulting costs and um that but there
will be ongoing maintenance costs after
that and warranty
okay thank you you're welcome
thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question I had a
two-part question but half of it's been
answered the number of employees
are those employees part of the New
Hampshire retirement system yes they are
thank you
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman thank you for being here today
so you mentioned in an answer to another
question that there's limited vacancies
that take place throughout the year so
just what is driving the overtime
uh expenditures so if if there's not
frequent vacancies uh vacancies what's
driving there to be overtime use
okay
um thank you very much for the question
representative Sweeney
um we the overtime is a call is caused
by numerous factors one factor is the
vacancies that happen periodically the
work still needs to get done even though
the person who is primarily responsible
for the work is not there
um there's also been because of the
software project there's a significant
amount of testing that needs to get done
as the different pieces get the
different the Liberals deliverables get
rolled out they have to get tested and
so that is in addition to our staff's
regular duties
and then there's also certain times of
the year that are just simply busier
than others for example
every year
um in
in the months cup preceding July which
is when we have the most retirements
with all of the teachers retiring
there's a lot of member services over
time and then in the months of October
and November in finance because of our
external audit there's a lot of overtime
there and so if Marie has any other
thank you very much
foreign
T are you working with them at all
doit yeah no we have our separate
because we're a component unit of the
state we have a separate I.T department
so all of our infrastructure everything
is separate from doit
foreign
thanks
representative Hewitt what's up
you have one more
I can generate as many questions all
right so we heard that um there's 42 000
recipients of Pensions right now there's
how many active employees are there
fifty thousand maybe it's a 48
500 active members okay
all right and um
this is somewhat of an aside but
something that brought up yesterday
could we find out
um for each of the four categories of
employees employee teacher police fire
um roughly take a year like 2000 how
many started versus how many
um became vested
you see what I mean how steep is that
funnel
because that would be an interesting
thing to know and I haven't been able to
to get that data yet so
um if you want to do it for more than
one year that's fine I don't care but
you know just a rough
okay we can take a look at that all
right thank you
seeing no further questions I do have a
question from Marty and if you were able
to come up with that analysis of that 50
million
yes okay
all right that's great thanks that's all
I have representative Weiler
thank you Mr chairman
um I've noted quite a bit of turnover in
in this agency I remember Marie was
D.O.T was it just a year or two ago and
how long have you been with him
I've on April 1st I will mark my second
anniversary
congratulations where did you come from
um New Mexico
I remember we've always drawn from all
over the country I remember previously
was Kentucky or something like that or
that the person didn't last long so I I
see quite a bit of turnover is that
present throughout the staff
um it has
been largely at the upper levels but a
lot of it had was planned in advance for
example my predecessor George Legos he
had he had his retirement
um in addition
um Larry Johansen who had been our
um
director of Investments had he had been
in that position for over 10 years 13
years and he also had a planned
retirement we've also had other staff
members leave for better opportunities
elsewhere it's been a combination of
things but I want you to know we have
worked very hard to bring in new
incredibly qualified
replacements for the vacancies that
we've had and we're we've become a
stronger
Agency for it I mean
Marie is just an example of one of the
the new members of senior staff and
she's a very strong professional yeah
she she comes with a reputation we all
know that she knows all the numbers so
anyway we're delighted that she's there
but
um you know it it also seems there's a
great deal of fluctuation in the
earnings of this fund I've never been
satisfied with who we have advising
for three or four years because I have
my own funds and I'm looking at them and
they do a little up and down but not as
much as this the funds in this agency
from plus 26 percent one year to minus
six the next year and I don't see that
happening and the other funds is as much
and wonder about the mixture of funds
and and why it's so
you know variable and and we had several
years where it was down around one
percent
so
I'm I'm doubtful about the advice you
have
anyway thank you well I I would like to
point out that in the 13 years that
we've had the independent investment
committee our performance has been very
strong relative to our peers and yes
there can be very significant
fluctuations in return from one year to
the next but that is what's happening
everywhere in the financial markets it's
nothing unique to New Hampshire
thank you
so thank you very much you did steal a
very good person from the D.O.T I know
they'd miss her over there so
um anyway see no further questions it
would appear that we're satisfied with
what you've offered again just a caution
as you may have heard me say earlier to
the division that we may have to have
you back should we find ourselves in
some sort of issue but I don't see that
happening here
uh and you did ask great questions one
of the most important things we do look
at is general fund dollars uh that's and
as she mentioned there are no general
fund dollars here we'll find with
insurance next or no general fund
dollars but that's not always the case
but those are the some of the important
issues well thank you very much Marty
we'll look forward to your email
Maybe
the general fund into it
so next we have insurance
um
and if you could introduce yourself
commissioner and I know your last name
it's very difficult to spell and I
recognize spell it and say it so we're
good uh thank you chairman members of
the committee my name is Chris
nicolopolis I'm the insurance
commissioner for the State of New
Hampshire I'm joined uh here by DJ
Bettencourt our Deputy Commissioner
behind me we have Christy rice our
assistant commissioner and Ted Perkins
our business operations guy between the
four of us we'll do the best to answer
any questions you might have
uh if it pleases uh the division I'd
like to just give you three or four
minutes about what we do at the
insurance department uh I think most of
you have heard from us before
um but it's important to understand that
New Hampshire insurance department was
the first insurance department in the
United States uh for an industry that is
primarily state-based uh regulation New
Hampshire was on The Cutting Edge of
that nearly a hundred and fifty years
ago 170 years ago 170 years ago we did
that uh we are our uh the commission is
charged with enforcing all insurance
laws which can be found in New Hampshire
between RSA 400 and 420 Q
uh and those uh those regulations
include the collection of Premium tax
fees the regulation of all insurance
companies in New Hampshire we have 1300
insurance companies 1300 companies that
are authorized to sell policies here uh
and nearly 200 000 Insurance Producers
or adjusters licensed to do business
with New Hampshire uh residents we
approve
um we approve licenses for all of those
folks when you get down to it the
mission of the insurance department can
be boiled down to Consumer Protection we
do that in five major ways first we
approve rates for every Insurance
product sold in the state and so when a
company uh proposes to sell a product
here we look at their rate and we
determine one of uh two things one that
it is not artificially high that they're
not charging more than necessary to pay
the claims but also that it's not
artificially low what we don't want a
company to do is come to New Hampshire
buy market share by pricing their
product too low uh thereby leaving in a
situation where they have inadequate
reserves to pay claims so that's the
first thing we do we also have a team of
people that approve every form every
document that you get related to your
insurance policy is reviewed by our team
and they're looking at it for compliance
with state law federal law where
applicable and a Centrist and so as they
go through those if they see some new
Innovative language a creative language
they'll bring it to our team and say is
this okay and we'll review that and
we'll make a decision based on what's
best for consumers and then ultimately
we'll change the law of the rule to make
sure that that's outlined for everyone
to understand
uh a third uh a kind of uh leg to our
consumer protection stool is our
financial stability and accuracy reviews
we have a team that reviews every
Financial record of companies here to do
business to make sure that they're
adequately and appropriately disclosing
their Investments their assets uh their
reserves so that we are not surprised
when an insurance company be becomes
financially challenged
uh most importantly the thing that we do
is we serve New Hampshire consumers we
have a team of seven people that assist
the Commissioners and I uh to work with
New Hampshire consumers in an almost 5
000 consumer increase a year come into
our department uh we manage those the
vast majority of them something like 80
percent are just increase it we can
answer because we're experts it might be
what's actual cash value mean what's
this provision in my contract mean how
do I know if my car is totaled uh but 20
of those turn into consumer
investigations where we uh will work
with the company we'll work with the
licensees we'll work with the producers
to determine whether or not any law was
uh violated that they complied with Fair
settlement procedures
um and ultimately direct the New
Hampshire consumer to understand what is
happening in their insurance transaction
we're proud of that work we could
probably spend this whole half an hour
talking about the great work we do there
and finally we have a team that does
targeted and random exams on insurance
companies to look at whether or not
they're complying with our laws so we
may go in and look at a health carrier
and see are they paying claims in a
timely manner are they processing claims
in accordance with their underlying
policies so all of that work uh and the
75 to 85 staff people that we have on
our team
that manage that
I think it's important to understand
that the insurance department is a
self-funded department so our budget uh
39 million dollars will be uh the
numerator in a in a formula where the
total assessment I'm sorry total premium
volume for the state in Hampshire is the
denominator and so it's about
.001 of a percent of insurance premium
that's funded for our department uh so
the entities that we regulate pay for
the cost of running the department
um I know most of this today will be
about our spending but it's important to
talk about what we do for collecting
general fund Revenue uh we collect
nearly 140 million dollars a year in
revenue for the State uh 125 million of
that is insurance premium tax we charge
uh
sales tax of one and a half percent to
two percent on insurance policies in the
state it is much much more complicated
than that and to explain all of that to
you would take several hours but assured
that every policy sold here is taxed at
at least our rate uh or at the higher
rate of what the uh uh State
um the home state of the insurance
company would charge our uh company if
they were taxed we collect five million
dollars in circle science tax those are
taxes on policies from insurance
companies that aren't regulated directly
by our market and those are for products
that are difficult to place
and then finally we collect uh somewhere
in the neighborhood of 19 million
dollars in fees
uh to our budget in large part our
budget isn't going to be surprisingly
different from what you've seen uh in
the past there are some changes we're
coming out of covid uh we're doing some
strategic planning and in large part
about 90 of our budget is uh
non-negotiable for us it's things like
salaries and benefits uh DOI T costs
rent costs pensions and and such
uh this year uh we are asking for three
new uh junior examiner positions and
that is uh because we are aware we are
well aware that our department is older
than average you know I think state
employees are generally older than uh
private sector uh folks and our
department is especially so and what
we're seeing as a
a team is that we're losing deep
knowledge bases as people retire and
what we need to do is to ensure that we
continue to have those resources
in-house we need the ability to bring on
some Junior examiners that we can train
up in the coming years so that we don't
lose that knowledge what we've seen
happen in other states that have already
gone through this transition is if they
are not proactive about it what they end
up with is no team left they don't have
a team of insurance company examiners on
their staff left to sufficiently cover
their work
their only answer then is to hire
outside Consultants outside Consultants
that do this same work charge on average
a thousand dollars a day for that work
by training the team in-house here we
maintain and retain that asset for the
State of New Hampshire so that we have
those people here it is a critical part
of ensuring that my department and our
department is ready for the next
Generation I believe in two or three
budget Cycles I will come back and be
able to ask to reduce remove three
positions after I'd adequately trained
and brought on those new folks and
turned over the people that are looking
to leave then I may not need those but I
anticipate for about three years will
I'm sorry three budgets will need to run
those through the the whole operation
I think there are 38 of our staff that
are insurance company examiners of some
sort
48 sorry 48 that was close uh 48 of our
team that are insurance company
examiners and so those will be run
through all the divisions
a couple other changes that are in our
budget uh that you might notice uh line
10 which is our general kind of office
expenses line that's where we buy our
paper and toner and uh ergonomic uh
necessary equipment and we're raising
that from 110 to 135 that's kind of a
catch-all for us
um on line 26 Do's
we pay dues to the NAIC the NAIC is a
group a National Association of
insurance Commissioners every state and
all the territories belong to the NAIC
uh in the NAIC is as the name says
insurance commission a group of
insurance Commissioners they pull
resources for us and uh for the dues we
pay them they return about a hundred
times back to us
what they do for a state like New
Hampshire I mentioned earlier that we
have 200 000 licensees NAIC processes
all of those and so instead of us having
to receive a paper application and a
check and process it in the computer and
verify that they've checked all the
right boxes and then add it to our
accounting and ASC does that for us
every day sends us a report of uh who's
updated their licenses and a check on
EFT
um that alone probably saves us 300 000
a year and they do that time and time
again for resources that all of the
Commissioners Across the Nation need uh
and so it's a tremendous resource the
increase in the dues this year is we
have not for the last two budgets
um funded are end coil position and end
coil is the national
uh committee for insurance legislators
and this is a resource for
um for State reps that are in that are
dealing with insurance issues to do the
same thing I'm doing at uh NAIC uh this
is something that a couple of State reps
have asked me about attending those
meetings so that they can go and be uh
be enlightened on what's Happening
Across the Nation and so the increase
here of fifteen thousand dollars is so
that we can fund the end coil uh dues
uh equipment line 30. um it's probably
presented wise probably our largest
increase we're going from 40 to 107. uh
for the last 10 years the department has
neglected to replace either of our two
vehicles and so we are now 10 years in
since we bought our last car
we use cars primary State business but
almost exclusively for our three fraud
investigators we have fraud
investigators under statute we're
required to investigate any referred
fraud to the state we investigate those
all over and because that takes a a toll
on the cars we provide cars at the
department for that we should have done
this four years ago and two years ago
but with covet in the tight budget we
put it off uh it is it is time and so
I'd like to keep that in the budget
um line 46 line 46 and line 102 are our
consultant and program Services we think
of those two lines together uh we are
bringing those lines back to
pre-pandemic levels uh a lot of our
external programming is run through
these lines namely
um healthcost.gov New Hampshire has the
first and best
health cost website in the nation
several states have copied us we've been
doing it for 15 years we collect
millions of lines of Health cost data
and make that available to Consumers we
do some of that in conjunction with DHHS
and so some of these contracted services
are supporting the database the analysis
uh and the reporting of that
uh these two lines combined also cover
our required annual hearing every year
we have a comprehensive hearing for all
people interested in health insurance to
explain what's happening in our
Marketplace that costs us about ninety
thousand dollars to have the Consultants
uh dig into all of the state and
National factors impacting health
insurance so that we as a department and
uh the industry as a whole understand
what's happening there
uh and we're bringing those back to
pre-pandemic levels
you'll notice in line 50 we have a temp
employee as part of the discussion that
we've had I've had with you today about
the turnover of our office we've used
this temporary employee line uh in
almost the entire time admin
commissioner which is now three in two
weeks I'll be commissioner three years
in a row uh three years now and we've
used that line almost entirely to
backfill when somebody surprises us with
I'm retiring we hire somebody new and we
use this temp position so that we can
bring them back to train for key
functions in their Department uh one of
them that we've used a couple of times
is our company licensing person it's a
very difficult job and we've had a
little bit of turnover there and we've
brought back a woman who's done that job
for uh for a career to train two people
now
I actually I'm sorry three people uh and
currently we're using it to help us get
through the legislative session we had
the
distinct opportunity to bring back our
former uh Deputy Commissioner Alex
valdable to help us do a legislative
session he is a uh he is a wealth of
knowledge and we lost uh our head of
life and health last year and he's
helping us hobble through so this uh
temporary employee line we will use
appropriately to make sure that we
continue delivering services
employee training there's a small
increase and that is driven
um by a training that didn't happen over
the pandemic we weren't able to travel
to some of our required credential
training for our teams and we need to
pick that back up and make sure that
they stay at the top of the game
uh and then finally
um the promotional line which is line 69
is an increase from 35 to 60. uh that
increase if you need a lot of detail uh
Deputy Commissioner or bet Court will
give it to you but this is our effort to
continue to make sure New Hampshire
consumers know we're here we have a lot
of resources and the the worst thing we
hear is I didn't know about you when I
needed you and so we have a
comprehensive program to get out DJ and
his team are running that and I'm sure
he'd be happy to go into more detail if
you have questions but other than that
we're happy to answer any questions on
our budget
represent McGuire
thank you Mr chairman thank you
commissioner
um on page 319 you're getting uh for one
year only half a million dollars from
the federal government for Consultants
what is that about
um that that is uh what's the name of
that
State Flex Grant uh it's a number of
programs coming from the federal
government to research and investigate
uh things that are changing our health
insurance uh landscape here in New
Hampshire it's a very rigid program
where we're able to look at certain
aspects of cost drivers for health
insurance we are preparing now uh to put
out rfps for that money it will look at
things like the total impact of mandates
and other cost drivers right now we're
looking at a pretty substantive shift as
part of our Medicaid redetermination
that's going to be happening in the
coming weeks so it'll be used for
long-term research projects directed by
uh federal government
thank you
um What's the total amount spent on
insurance in New Hampshire and and and
in each category I mean Auto and
homeowners and whatever General that's
an awesome question it's one I like to I
generally like to ask people as a trivia
question uh it is uh almost seven
billion dollars
uh seven billion dollars in insurance
and it's roughly I have a chart here
roughly three billion 3 billion and one
billion being PNC health and then other
products
I thought I had a chart here honestly so
your 0.001 I think is actually 0.2
percent
because you're spending 14 million out
of 7 billion
so a percent of 7 billion would be
um 70 million right and so you're 0.2 of
that I I guess you're right okay um I
think I think part of that factor is
that last year we returned almost 2
million of that money uh and the neic
provides us that calculation as a
compare all of our states together and I
they may be capturing uh products that
aren't regulated here
one last question so how many new
companies who haven't previously done
work in new sold Insurance in New
Hampshire have come in in the last
couple of years I Pro another great
question I probably signed a new license
once a week you know it's a very active
very active in part they're not they're
not entirely new companies you know it's
a division of Geico that is you know
rolling out a new product here there are
some new companies as they go across the
nation you know one of the facts that I
like to share to you know so that my own
britches don't get too big is that the
New Hampshire Marketplace the insurance
Marketplace that we regulate is 0.4 of a
percent less than half a percent of the
Nationwide Marketplace that's our
population and so people aren't sitting
in New York or Hartford saying you know
what we need to do we need to break into
New Hampshire like that is the market uh
and the way we do that the way we
attract folks is having a a in a
business approach that Embraces them and
encourages them to come here and to
allow them to appropriately rate
policies
uh and that's why almost all of our
markets are what we consider competitive
markets there are lots of companies
willing to write your risk namely the
only one that's currently not
competitive is medical malpractice
insurance
everything else is competitive
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here to take questions from us
um you mentioned adding three employees
for the the junior program uh lines 10
and 11 almost when combined for what was
authorized in 2023 and what's proposed
for 2024 seemed to be pretty even so I'm
wondering if there are other Staffing
reductions that are in this budget or
movements in order to get to those three
uh that was astute of you uh to see that
the junior examiner positions are would
be some of our lowest paid positions so
they're not substantial positions and
also part of this transition iPad where
my senior staff is retiring and being
replaced with people is offsetting that
and so
um I think we will see that because they
didn't they don't earn a whole bunch and
there's only three that's what it is
I've set by one follow-up
um sort of separate subject are you are
we seeing an increase in Insurance scams
along the lines of every other scam that
seems to be increasing yeah your
department interacts with and deals with
yes okay and where New Hampshire has
taken a very proactive approach on this
we were the first to go after or
the First Health sharing Ministry his
name alternative Trinity and alert we're
the first state in the nation to do that
we were the first state in the nation to
look at uh mental health parity uh we
today signed a settlement agreement with
another Health sharing scam Jericho and
so we're watching those very closely and
when we get a settlement so we get in
early before the company has roots here
so we can get them out
uh and we and if they don't agree to
leave we will find them we're taking
that very seriously yeah one thing I
would highlight along with that and it's
a bit of a frustration so take this as a
bit of a PSA we're seeing a lot of
complaints coming in with regard to the
sale and promotion of Medicare Advantage
and the problem that we have there is we
do not have authority over Medicare
Advantage the State lost its oversight
of that function of that program with
the Medicare modernization act back in
the early 2000s we do our best and we
direct consumers to the federal process
to get their issues addressed but what I
can tell you is
um
I admire people like Joe Namath and
William Shatner but don't take your
Medicare Advantage advice from them
um start there and and if it sounds
fishy it probably is fishy and they're
using
um third-party offshore
call centers to really harass people
yeah it's bad we have a um a guy in our
department who tried to do a little
undercover work and tried to get through
the system so he could figure out who
they were rooting people to and we were
trying to see if we could somehow get at
this by getting directed to a New
Hampshire license he was using these
call centers when they're not licensed
to sell or solicit insurance we weren't
successful but what it did do is it
rendered his phone practically useless
it just rang all day because the word
went out that we may have a live one
here and everybody just swarmed in so
that's another really big one in
frustrating one that we've been seeing
and while we're here in front of you
because this is such a critical issue
for us if in your uh if in your uh
communities you're hearing about this or
there's an opportunity for one of our
experts to come out and educate folks
reach out to us we DJ and I have done
Road shows in Pizza Halls rotary uh
Chambers of Commerce we have an expert
that can do that for different groups
and we're happy to because it's just
another opportunity to educate people
about some of these Bad actors
representative Cambridge
yes thank you Mr chair
um in terms of the and thank you for
being here for explaining what you guys
do because I I frankly didn't know that
it even existed
um in terms of the effective
effectiveness of your department in
protecting the New Hampshire consumer
how's your record look in terms of uh
companies that may have folded because
you say you audit them to protect uh
what's the record look like in the past
few years in terms of companies that
have folded and left our people high and
dry uh well last few years Euro the last
major insolvency uh was 1998.
now the the only caveat to that is one
of the health insurers 10 years ago
um wrapped up but health insurance isn't
exactly like regular Insurance
um none and it's in part because the
we're not doing it alone and so the way
these Financial exams work are your key
State the state that you are domiciled
in kind of heads in exam but you do it
in conjunction with all of the other
states or many of the other states where
they write business and then our
analysis the way we examine them is
examined by Auditors to make sure we're
getting it right because it is so
critical
uh and what we see is states that are
good at our job and we are we are the
best at our financial
um analysis our financial analysis team
is the best we lit they literally take
our team members to teach the rest of
the this the nation
um companies that are questionable don't
come here
if you want to do something Suspect with
the reserves you're not coming to a
place like New Hampshire
and I would just add in terms of
consumer satisfaction we are required by
Statute to survey the consumers that we
interact with to make sure that we're
hitting some quality metrics and we've
taken that very very aggressively we
actually have an individual who
individually calls every consumer that
our consumer division touches and when
we started this I was a little bit
nervous because you know it tends to be
the case that the consumer who you're
able to successfully help them with
their issue they're going to be happy
with you whereas the consumer who comes
to you and we have to tell them look
you're in an erisa plan that's Federal
uh that's that's a federal program
you've got to go to the feds are
probably not as happy or somebody who
comes to us and there's no regulatory
violation by the company
probably not happy with us what I was
thrilled about is that the approval
rating the satisfaction rating of
consumers that respond to us is 90
regardless of whether or not their case
was handled the way they wanted it to be
handled or not uh which
um I'm very proud of it means that our
team is knowledgeable they're respectful
and they're getting back to people in a
timely manner regardless of how the
issue ends up resolving
I have a few questions or representative
Weiler
thank you Mr chairman welcome DJ good to
see you I'm looking for where dues are
pointed out in the budget I used to be a
required
thing and they don't I don't see a line
that says dues
it's my expenditure line 26 I am looking
at a different printout than you have
um
it says organizational dues
all right found it thank you and one of
the other questions I have if I may
is the uh is one particular
automobile repair shop and always
complains to me and I'm sure to you
about unfair treatment that if
this Chevrolet was being repaired at the
Chevrolet agency no questions pay it but
when he wants to to
repair it you don't approve the same
level of
of payment
well first off representative we don't
approve we don't approve repair
estimates uh there there is a process in
New Hampshire law for how uh two types
of repair shops deal with uh authorized
repairs uh there's something called a
in-network shop somebody who has a
pre-existing kind of pre-agreed to
arrangement with uh insurance carriers
and they could have them with several
and then there are independent shops uh
independent shops likely are the ones
who are making a call like this to you
and they don't have a pre-existing
relationship and so they have to
negotiate what their repair would be
because because in New Hampshire
Insurance consumer is able to go to
whatever repair shop they choose they
cannot be directed to a contracted shop
they get a chance to go to somebody
who's not in network we need to have
Direction in our law that says how
you're going to get paid back and the
direction that New Hampshire has adopted
is independent shop gives a quote
insurance company thinks that it's not
Market they go to another independent
shop get a competing quote from another
shop who isn't a network and that would
the higher of them prevails
um it's not a perfect system we do
handle lots of those calls I would
encourage this person to call our team
call DJ and we'll work with them but
it's you know uh
we don't decide what the reimbursement
rates are
thank you
I have a question representative
you mentioned settlements and stuff do
you work with the AG's office at all or
are you sort of a what's the overlap
there so our team they are not um sworn
officers so our Three Investigators on
our fraud team investigate potential
fraud put together a package that that
might outline fraud and then we turn
that over to a prosecutor either Federal
prosecutor or County prosecutor
typically not the AG
um and for our for the enforcement or
Market conduct stuff and that's for our
licensees people who are violating our
law who are regulated by our department
we do that internally
um we do work with AGS we fund a
position at the AGS to help our
department
um but we
there's kind of separate tracks the
criminal track that they might would be
different from ours
so I have a couple of questions uh I see
that last the last actual budget was
about 11 million dollars in round
numbers and under your proposed
Governors it's gone up to about 14
million dollars is that going to require
any sort of fee increases like the
insurance premium tax or uh I think uh
the actual expenses for 22 were 11
million the actual authorized budget for
uh for 23 was in fact 13.2 and so the
increase is 800 000 or so between what
the governor has and what our last
year's authorized budget was that will
mean the assessment to insurance
companies will go up
whatever that eight hundred thousand
dollars
um they uh the companies are very
supportive of the department keeping our
expertise in-house they understand that
it is far cheaper for me to train and
keep my insurance company examiners on
staff rather than use outside
Consultants uh and so I think to the
extent that you would hear from them
they would be uh more than supportive of
this number
so as far as a percentage what kind of
an increase because again I'm just
looking now at the uh actual expenses I
know you were authorized
said six percent six percent I I'm doing
that in my head so
um it's 800 over thirteen two
or nine hundred over thirteen two
so looking at uh travel I think that was
what fifteen thousand and now you're
looking for the recommendation 24 of up
to 63
000. seems like a pretty substantial
increase
uh I believe uh ins uh out of state
travel I believe is going from 50
authorized in 23 to 63. uh the 15 which
was our actual 4 22 was because uh in
part we didn't travel a lot during covet
and uh in part because as part of our
dues from NAIC that I mentioned earlier
they provide uh one they fund me to to
travel to those meetings and they also
provide 20 000 a year to offset uh
educational travel for our staff which
we didn't use in 20 and 21 and so we had
a big pool with them
to use which we used uh which we used
last year and so given free money from
NAIC or State uh State authorized
Revenue I use the free money first that
money is gone we used all of the backlog
of that money we will have 20 000 in
next year's budget just like we always
do
um right
yeah certainly again you don't use any
general funds but I always get concerned
that we say we're just going to pass it
on to the insurance companies which pass
it on to the consumer
so uh
we understand that and it's you know
when you're talking about 48 insurance
company uh Market examiners these are
these are top-notch experts in their
field and there are there is some
training that's required to keep them
um kind of up to speed on financial
accounting and Market conduct
examinations when you divide that over
the whole team it's it's probably one
and a half trips a year
so when you make those adjustments you
have to notify anyone in the legislature
or that you're bringing their rates up
by six percent or you do that and
hopefully nobody brings it to anybody's
attention we're doing that here yeah
um and and it is not bringing it up by
six percent if you ultimately if you
tell me we can't bring Junior examiners
on and we can't fund all your positions
um we will be forced to use Consultants
which get billed directly to the
companies outside of the budget so the
company the Consultants work they build
the company's hundreds of thousands and
it doesn't come through our budget the
companies are not better off now I
remember your predecessor used to like
to use Consultants uh he had a different
view of the value of the team the the
asset that I'm protecting is insurance
commissioner consumers first but the
experts on my team second there is
somebody when when one of you calls me
and says I have a consumer who's in
trouble
I take my phone and I walk to that
expert as we're talking you're telling
me the story I walk in and depending on
who your issue what your issue is I get
to their office I hit speakerphone I
restate the issue to understand that I
got it right and they tell you the
answer
and that's worth what we're using it
just is
all right any further questions
representative McGuire thank you did the
pandemic put any life insurers on the
ropes or cause them to leave the
business
did not and we were really concerned
about that uh really really concerned
about the impact of the pandemic on a
lot of insurance you know initially
nobody's drove cars and then we were
worried about increased deaths
um and I think there was some impact
there and they're not not substantive it
did not change anybody's solvency I
think there are some aspects of it that
it may have helped you know if if people
no longer run long-term care insurance
because they they passed away
um it it kind of evened out uh they they
account for
um over the course of a relationship
with an insured uh for accruing for that
and said no
thanks
any further questions representative
Weiler
you're unclassified uh positions seem a
fairly high percentage is it a special
class that then includes uh we have a
lot of unclassified positions nearly 20
of my staff are unclassified is that
right and it may actually be slightly
more than that and it's because we have
a really broken record we have a lot of
experts you know
um we've got insurance company actuaries
that would be off step our Market
conduct uh the directors of our
divisions would be off step and so we
have a number of those positions that
are there it provides the insurance
commissioner as they change some ability
to to build his own team around him uh
and also to be dynamic as things change
uh it works well for us
are you having any trouble with
retention like we're hearing from other
departments absolutely the reason I'm
the reason I I'm kind of being
foreshadowing a loss of talent is
because that's exactly what's happening
and we knew it you know five years ago I
was not commissioner but I was in the
industry and I listened to Roger say to
you all I'm worried about the grand of
the department uh
four years ago Roger said that I'm sorry
uh John Elias said that I've lived it
and I'm losing I lost my entire tax team
in the last 18 months I was two people
and they were amazing the best that we
could have ever had some of the most
complicated work that's done here in the
insurance department and so we are and
retaining them we're not losing them to
other departments in large part we're
losing them to retirement I'll return
okay
all right see no further questions it
looks like you may not have to come back
but thank you so much okay thanks oh I
need a hard copy
I didn't I just have some notes I do
have a copy of the presentation we gave
to ways I mean just has all the
background what the department does I'm
happy to leave that that'd be great
yeah okay
thank you thank you
I wonder if if we have
more self-funded agencies than a lot of
other states
years ago we had labor was kind of
self-funded and people complained that
there wasn't enough control so we we
took the monies they were making and
bringing in and made them into going to
the general fund and we funded them out
of the general fund it was kind of a
wash but
some people think we have more control
that way
you remember savini who was an insurance
he didn't have a lot of people but he
contracted everything so
I guess is good and bad about both
you know and there's nothing we can do
about it because there's no General
funds
Board of tax and land Appeals
yeah you're both welcome to come up
what was that
all right
and if you could just introduce
yourselves and if you have a difficult
last name spell it for our clerk that
would be great
I think
sorry about that with me is Aunt
stelmack she's a board's Clerk and it's
s-t-e-l-m-a-c-h
um
pardon me and
with an e
we'd like to thank you for the
opportunity to speak to provide an
overview of the board's budget for the
fiscal 2024 and
2025 bun biennium
the
do you know what page is
the budget is has a funding split of 90
General funds and 10 Highway funds the
board's mission is to provide an
appellate Forum that is timely Fair
inexpensive and readily accessible to
taxpayers and property owners
its expertise and tax and real estate
matters give the public a knowledgeable
and neutral body to appeal thus ensuring
unbiased and transparent resolution of
their matters and for your information
there's a list of the matters appealable
on pages 11 and 12 of your budget
foreign
maybe a different page
you have the let me just see where it's
after
I don't believe we have that document
that you're referring to Mr Hoffman
sure that'd be great thank you
under RSA 71b5 the Boyd's jurisdiction
is to hear and determine all matters
regarding questions of Taxation
appeals by the municipalities of their
equalized valuation which is determined
by the Department of Revenue
Administration
just compensation and eminent domain
here taking pursuant to RSA chapter
498-a and all matters relating to the
need for reassessments by municipalities
the board's budget as you can see is a
maintenance budget
although the economy has resulted in
higher expenses in some classes we were
still able to meet the governor's
targeted numbers and the governor has
approved the prioritized needs which are
the doit and rent for the building that
we reside in which is Johnson Hall in
the gallon Office Park
and based on that the board respectfully
requests you approve the budget and we
would be happy to answer any questions
that you may have and we thank you for
your time
well you've both been around a long time
good to see familiar faces don't retire
no no every time yet good other
questions representative Sweeney thank
you Mr chairman thank you both for being
here today uh really a quick question uh
10 and 11 the
pretty balanced between classified and
unclassified employees I don't know if
you can provide more insight as to
why that there's a balance there or
would you like to answer that I sure
would
so class 10 is comprised of we have
myself two other full-time staff
currently a vacant review appraiser so
that gets us to for full-time and a
part-time which is embedded in class 50.
so we're very small office there's seven
um three
unclassified to which Michelle is one of
the three and we're all permanent
full-time employees and the reason it's
balanced is because I have 22 years you
don't want to ask her how many years but
we're all maxed out we've been around a
long time so the longevity we don't have
a high turnover rate the challenge with
the review appraiser is just because
um we're competing
where we can't compete with the private
sector for that position because of its
technical expertise so we're going to
try what we're hoping for the raise and
if if that might help us fill that that
might make it more competitive if if
that passes so um but yeah we're a very
small office and we've all just been
there probably way too long if that
helps
represent Weiler
thank you Mr chairman so are your board
members not listed as employees we at
class 11 with the unclassified
and we are listed as as employees
and
um
the other question that
I was thinking of was um
the fees that you collect the filing
fees they're not shown here what what
portion of of your expenses do they
amount to do you think
we charge most of our filing fees we
have over 70 statutes that are
appealable and those are all 65 dollars
per appeal so we average about 400
appeals a year
we're not generating a lot of Revenue
anywhere between 55 000 and 60 000 a
year the eminent domains kick up to a
hundred dollars the state DOT usually
files maybe 10 to 15 takings a year
so we're not
I couldn't even do that math it's going
to be probably one percent or less of
what
work and all that money does go back to
the general fund
yeah I thought maybe it should be shown
here as as the totals thank you
thank you what is the transfer from the
Department of Transportation
um line two near the bottom of page 179.
um that is the tent represents the 10 of
the budget where we're basically using
do we are DOT transfers
um
that portion of our budget to compensate
for the eminent domain work that we do
because a lot of their stuff is federal
it's not really Highway fund they call
it other and it's fuel inventory
maintenance 22 years I don't really know
what that means but it's somewhere
embedded it's not strictly a highway
fund but it's they call it something
related to highway so it's 10 we do it's
been stagnant at 10 because that 10
percent represents of our total caseload
approximately how much of that is
focused on them in a domain and the time
spent on those files so that's the
taxation portion consumes the 90 if you
will so it's we build I build dot
quarterly for that those expenses
related to that 10 and they transfer and
they we don't only receive takings from
the state we also receive them from
municipalities
um school districts and various other
public and cities
so I guess I'm not familiar with the
board at all
are you the people making the decisions
about
who who's right who's wrong or or are
you more like staff of the end of the
appointed and it's the cleric of the
board which is very similar to a clerk
of court she manages the docket and the
staff and
does all the other work involved with
running the office as a chair I
typically run the hearings and we need a
quorum of two we have three members we
need a quorum of two to sit
our hearings are very much like hearing
center Court
but they're much less stringent where
where especially if we receive Pros as
coming in to testify we allow them a lot
of Liberty to present their case but
once we receive the evidence from both
the taxpayer and then the municipality
then we
deliberate and and write a decision our
decision is appealable to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court so we have to
make findings in fact and rulings of law
what fraction of your decisions are
appealed
[Music]
currently we have two
um it's usually under two about two or
three a year not many out of considering
the volume no it's it's low very low
under one percent for sure what's the
overall volume
on a rolling basis so you get your tax
bill usually late fall okay so what
happens is you have until that that
March is the abatement deadline and then
that following September so almost you
know nine months after your bill is the
appeal for that tax here so we're it
looks like we're always behind but we
will end up every September with about
400 appeals we always at that time in
the year still have
a couple 300 to 300 open so we're
chronically have like this rolling seven
750 it just they go out but they come
back it's like a wave right I equate it
to the ocean as much as leaves comes
right back in so yeah we're running
about a seven seven to eight hundred
depends on the year it also depends on
reval Cycles when Manchester does a
reval I know it's going to be a good
year as far as business
um it's job security but then you know
when the rebels if they're not getting
done the larger cities if they do them
every five years which most don't but
most of them do them more frequently so
we get that influx
um but typically what the court sees are
usually issues of law issues of first
precedence their job is to determine
valuation
um on all of whether it's a state tax
appeal whether it's it's property tax
it's uh exemptions it's it's all they're
all slightly different but the general
thread is valuation and the court will
take a few like I said usually they're
interesting cases that just are hinging
on a word in the statute that no one can
interpret or doesn't
it that's usually the linchpin is the
law and then three a year maybe on
average not a lot we we just received
um a copy of a decision I think a month
or two ago it was Rama which is a
Rochester Fair
it was an exemption appeal and the board
determined that it was a charitable
purpose therefore they were exempt from
paying taxes and it went up to the
Supreme the Supreme Court and it took
them almost a year to decide that one
and they just did and issued an opinion
affirming the board's decision
Okay so
is there some particular I'm sorry is
there some particular
RSA or group of rsas that generate 50 of
your case or something that are
especially problematic and if we did
something to clear them up it would
make half your cases go away or
something like that is there
yes
well most of our decisions are our
appeals at property tax Appeals
um they are some are problematic some a
contamination appeals some are we've had
the Mount Washington hotel a lot of
larger properties industrial commercial
properties are appealing now we've got
a case coming up on Tuesday that we
participate will last all day it's with
the attorneys and appraisers and it
I haven't even had a chance to look at
it yet I've never heard about it it's a
movie theater yes so it's really about
judgment what is something really worth
right is that it's it's not about law
it's about no but it's based on the
evidence and we and it and it is law
because we it has to be a legal opinion
if we air
on on a legal
case
um then they have the right to take it
up to the Supreme Court
it's a fascinating board
if you wanted to take your case to the
Superior Court you could do that or take
it to this board and these the board
members are appointed by the Supreme
Court
so they do have the Supreme Court
connection as they are appointed by the
Supreme Court but but that's the only
connection we do have with them yeah
representative hatch followed by
represent Senator Universe I'm amazed
that
um you're able to adjudicate all that
you do with the resources you have to do
so so I mean what outside resources do
you do you have to hire
um other entities or
individuals or you just do all this
within the house we do it in-house
um
we tried this past year to have we went
to the fiscal committee and the governor
and Council to have the funds for the
review appraisal position transferred
into a class 102 contract
um
and we haven't been able to work that
out where we can get someone who isn't
maybe biased
um to do that would be working on
revaluations and that's pretty intense
and so we're back to trying to get the
review appraisal position filled but we
also are very short on staff
um and our staff is not knowledgeable in
the work that Anne does and she's one of
those people if she leaves it's going to
be a position that's going to be very
hard to fill
um
and we do we do have would like and and
we were talking we've already been
talking about the next biennium
um requesting another employee that
would be more of a manager type that
could
do a lot of the duties that she does now
that she just
she quite frankly she does the job of
two to three people I you know
so you don't have a very deep bench
that's where I mean that's a concern in
other words if either of you are not
available what happens
um
seriously I mean
it's a problem yes if if one of the
other of us retired or went to another
job
I know a lot of Anne's job because I
work very closely with her as a chair
and my former job was as the clerk but
that position has evolved so much over
the years that it would be difficult for
me to carry on my own duties and try and
train somebody and do her duties in the
interim so are you budgeting to take
care of that Gap that we have it to me
this this seems like a pretty critical
problem that needs to be addressed
post-hason
it's been
since 2008 when our budget and cutbacks
had been made and it was just a steady
chop chop chop chop and eventually you
know we're at the point yeah if you take
one more away God the wheels are going
off
um
but I I credit
and and I appreciate everything chair
LeBron is saying um and I appreciate the
the feedback but I credit we do what we
do and I believe in the efficiencies and
I am probably that was one of my strong
suits is efficiency and I desperately
need the oit budget to pass because I
cannot do what I do without the software
to do it the software that we have
invested in is one reason I can do what
I do with three people but if one of us
is out you know right now yeah there's
one person in our office along with one
board member and and it's okay I we
we've been able to adapt be efficient
and I can't run it any more smoother
than it is but I said as we you know I'm
going to be approaching you know
retirement at some point and I said yeah
we we need to get another full-time body
but you know how difficult that is to to
get sometimes we've asked multiple times
for another body and they say no so you
have to do what you have to do and you
have to adapt so that's what we've been
able to do but the software is critical
to me because I can't do push as much
paper as I do without that software and
if that thing breaks it really
it would not be pretty but um body wise
we we limp along and Band-Aid it as we
have to do and that's just the reality
of a small agency I I don't have you
know we used to when I first started in
2002 we had a staff we were an agency of
12.
and there were set you know it was a
four-person board the rest were staff
that I managed and over the years it's
just pick them off one by one and here
we are so yeah our intent is we're going
to put a 7D in as we've done before and
next budget try it again
that's all we can do that's further
question
representing
thank you and thanks definitely for
everything you're doing I was um
I was curious to the vast majority of
people appealing abatement decisions Etc
come from your board as opposed to going
straight to the Superior Court
I think the vast majority does we've
we've tried to investigate that in the
past and there are a lot that go to the
superior court but the ones that do are
like the public service companies
because they've come to us before and
they don't like our decisions and they
they're looking for more more cash back
so they think going to the court where
they only have one judge sitting at they
may have a better chance at winning the
case
there are several people that do that on
a regular basis but I think the vast
majority come to the board it's also a
250 dollar filing fee with the court and
a 65 filing fee with the board and we've
heard from so many people after a
hearing that they appreciate the
attention they get that we listen we ask
questions and
we're aware of the law and they
understand that when they leave
so do you have a sense of how many
appeals are actually granted I mean it
gives you a sense of how good the
assessors are doing I guess that's my
math we we don't keep track of that it'd
be very difficult to do that because
it's based on the property that's being
appealed and it's also based on the
evidence that comes in
there are cases that that get granted
that
um
because a lot of people will come in
with appraisers and good appraisers see
the commercial industrial properties
they'll have appraisals testify and do
reports
um sometimes we find that the
municipalities are not doing as much as
they could be doing
we have everyone go through a mediation
cycle before we schedule hearings and we
find when
the hearing is held that the taxpayer
will say well they didn't really tell us
that they didn't make an offer to us
when we were in mediation now we walk in
the door and now they're offering us
something
so
I think the the assessors could be doing
a better job
and I hope there aren't any in here
listening
[Laughter]
helpless
representative Hewitt I you have
mentioned that uh you thought that the
transfers to oit were very very very
important uh looking at the numbers that
comes the numbers here on the page
approach insignificance basically based
on the grand total of what we're going
to spend what is the why why is the
transfer to oit and very important my
software license is is uh
if if I don't maintain the database and
maintain the software and if it breaks
we have a technical issue a glitch
whatever you want to call it they're my
lifeline so if it if it goes down and I
know that is a small number probably
compared to what other people spend on
software but it's our our bread and
butter that's our lifeline and I don't
wanna
it's important to me because even though
it's a small it and it's actually it's
under 10 000 for the license
um and the rest of it is licenses for
Microsoft and all the other products
this product is is wonderful because it
integrates with Microsoft very nicely
and we've had it since
2007 when we went from dos so we've come
a long way
hello there we go uh part of our job is
to find out the things that that are
important and sometimes something like
that can be overlooked because as I say
that's not a heck of a lot of money uh
but it it a little bit of money can
become extremely important thank you
you mentioned uh the takings of the dot
comes in with how long does that
generally take to move through the
process a file and you render a decision
and
do you want to answer that I sure can
um typically
um
the dot by the time it's come to the
board they've already tried and
attempted to negotiate with the
landowner the landowner has refused the
offer of just compensation so when it
gets to the board it effectually
transfers the title from that landowner
once they file that taking now dot has
possession of that land so now the issue
before the board comes just compensation
the landowner has a right after it's
filed within 30 days of the taking they
have a right to go to Superior Court
will they first come to the board and
ask but they may want to fight the
taking and the necessity of the taking
is the taking truly necessary does the
state or the town really have to put the
road there
so that process could go to the Superior
Court we would I have to transfer those
if it's a taking that they're
questioning that necessity the whole God
that could take the court a year we had
one in Portsmouth of the one I've I've
only seen it happen this one time the
case was open with us for 10 years it
got so tied up in the court system so
here one from us to Superior Court up to
the Supreme Court back down up and down
over it's like chess
and the court ultimately decided there
was no need for Portsmouth to do what
they did and take the land
so then what had happened in that case
is it comes back again this is now we're
on year nine of just the legal finagling
and then they had to decide
wasn't the the just compensation for the
part taken it was the just compensation
for what was temporarily taken while it
wasn't a taking so it becomes a
different valuation issue and of course
now it's back in court so I figure 20
years from now we'll that'll get
resolved but it was that was the only
one I've ever seen mostly it takes a
year not to be long-winded it's it's
probably a good year because they have
that right if they don't go to the court
then
um they're going to want to get those
appraisals it's embedded in law that the
the dot must pay up to a thousand
dollars for those folks to to get an
appraisal they help pay for that because
this is a process nobody wants to go
through like I wouldn't wish this on
anybody you're losing either all or part
of your land sometimes permanent most of
the time permanent sometimes temporary
could be just drainage
they're paying for or a temporary
easement but most of the time it's
permanent loss so they get that option
so they have to get an appraiser that
takes time we try I try to schedule them
obviously we have they have to go view
the property
so I I don't typically make them go
snowshoeing I wait until good weather so
that it's dry they can see the land they
can see what was what exactly the
project that whoever was doing what that
looks like so yeah within a year they're
typically in and out we make those more
of a priority but it does depend on the
season too so okay thanks that was
helpful
any further questions
seeing none you may be off the hook
although uh Mr Hoffman has something to
hand out her I'm sorry I just wanted to
clarify because the documents that you
have looked a little bit different and
this is relatively fresh it's the
governor's budget just two days ago and
I wanted you to have a peek at that
poit line to make sure that we're
talking about the same numbers
sorry about that
and we're lucky to have Mr Hoffman he
double checks and triple checks our work
and I think
I think I gave him my entire initial
budget
for him to make copies of our
appeals that I mentioned on pages 11 and
12. so I think you may have looked at
what what was originally asked for and
they would there were changes made
subsequent to that and we do have the
governor's budget
all right we'll keep up the good work
and I don't think we'll need to see you
again unless someone differs with that
thanks very much
they were all so easy and I
raise the feed to 100
so my colleague representative McGuire
said if you raised your fee would you be
able to afford if you will another
employee which you obviously 800 cases
extra hundred dollars eighty thousand
dollars right so there's
foreign
oh Beauty has played it but I'm not sure
what the year but we have asked multiple
times to have that being reached to our
dollars because
you know 65 when you've got a commercial
emergency
right so have you thought about as a
percentage of the amount of dispute
rather than the fixed
number one we don't even know what the
amount
represents Sweeney has a question now
just to clarify so it's 250 dollars to
take the same case to the superior court
or they could pay 65 and talk to you
yeah
I mean I think we would just see less
caselope I think the caselo would shift
yeah and then the new so
but I'll bet there are 800 cases is much
higher than the new judge we just added
to this area is going to handle right I
mean he's going to do what is he going
to do 100 cases or something
yeah well that's mainly Zoning for I
think that it's a zoning issue yeah
first is an appraisal you want to take
some of these kids I don't believe so no
1977. okay do you know when you tried to
raise the fee before
I was not the last biennium I think it
was a prior one
um yeah I don't think so I've talked to
the governor's office about it before
and I'm talking to the legislature and
nothing has happened so if I mean did
you have a bill put in I'm sorry if I
may did you have a bill put into Ways
and Means to adjust the fee or how did
you go about that
how would you go about it how did you
get it how did you oh how I think
through testimony and discussions with
the governor's budget director
um and they based on the the economy
they didn't want to add anything to
taxpayers appealing to us so
okay thank you very well thank you we'll
give it some thought thank you very much
oops yes I will think
it doesn't
all right next we have the executive
Council
sorry we delayed you a little bit
all right state your name or the record
please good morning still my name is
Megan Rose and I am the executive
assistant for the office of the
executive Council
so I have a handout that I prepared for
you today which is kind of just a
snapshot of what our office is
as small as it is and the amount of
space we take up or are responsible for
across the state the entire State and
how that's broken up for the executive
counselors it touches on our prioritized
needs and just a little bit of a recap
of
a very small recap of
or overview of our calendar year 2022
and some of the things that we did in
our office
so we are a very small office it's the
five executive counselors who are all
elected officials the office staff is
myself and then we have in our budget a
part-time office assistant which is
actually in one of our our prioritized
needs
um are it's important that you know we
are ensuring public access to the
citizens of New Hampshire that they can
reach the counselors through their
office in Concord
um as well as on their cell phones and
at their home offices and on the road
which they often do
um and that we me and the part-time
person support them administratively one
by being here today and two with the
various things that they ask of us or
need for us for Council meetings for
public hearings information sessions
should we need them and there are other
day-to-day activities
one of my favorite slides I think that I
put together
um is just the district map of the
council so
um a little bit about me I will insert
in here is simply that I've been a state
employee for the better part of 20 years
I have had the privilege of working for
other small agencies started with the
Labor Relations Board years ago worked
for
the Secretary of State's office the
executive Council as the part-time
assistant years ago I've worked for the
judicial branch briefly and then also
for the governor's office and found my
way back to the council because
apparently that is where I belong that
is where I enjoy helping the public and
I enjoy working for the counselors but
if you look so when I first joined the
council we were back with Governor Lynch
and this was not
the map
it was two maps ago uh and then we
switched back in 2010 from the 2010
census and learning those new districts
was quite a challenge and so I put this
in here for you all because it helps me
to get used to the new the lines
um it kind of breaks down the square
miles that each of the counselors is
responsible for covering and how many
towns and cities are in their District
knowing that it's separated equal by
population which I'm sure all of you
know and I'm sure you're all getting
used to your new districts as well
so the core function of the executive
council is to authorize expenditures of
the executive branch
authorizing justice of the peace and
notary applications they confirm
appointments to the over 300 estate
boards and commissions through that are
mostly volunteer throughout the state of
New Hampshire as well as agency heads
and then by Statute judicial nominees
and Public Utility Commission nominees
they hold public hearings on both of
those nominees and state agency heads at
their discretion
um the judicial and public utility
nominees are required by law for them to
hold public hearings
and they also participate in the 10-year
Highway plan as members of gasset the
governor's advisory Commission on
Intermodal Transportation where they
hold meetings throughout their districts
and take input from the towns and cities
on priorities that they want addressed
as they redraft and move forward
um
on the 10-year Highway plan
so as you'll have seen in our budget
documents the prioritized needs we are
asking for includes a request to
increase funding for the executive
Council stipends the executive council
do receive a stipend each which is paid
out to them monthly and that covers the
cost of their travel it covers the costs
it's supposed to cover like travel costs
and the costs they incur from like
working throughout the district and
working oftentimes away from the the
council office and in their District
they're traveling in hundreds of miles
which I'm sure we can all appreciate and
relate to but they're using their
personal phones they're using their home
offices as well
um back in the day they were apparently
assigned way before my time they were
assigned State phones at one point in
time but that went by the wayside years
ago and they figured with the amount of
travel that the counselors were doing
this was the best way to encapsulate a
reimbursement for that
the last time that that was increased at
all was back in fiscal year 2010 again
before my time serving with the council
and in all the years it has not been
increased I am aware that I don't want
to say approximately six or so seven
maybe years ago there was talk about
them asking for an increase but then the
election was held the counselors changed
and thus everything the direction that
things were going also changed
so so just a quick follow-up to what you
just told us sure what's the stipend now
the stipend now is district one gets
seven 750 a month and the other
districts get 500.
well we have a little break in the
action any questions uh before that's a
lot of Representative McGuire in here
what's this under organization notes
those are twelve thousand dollars is
this
that's not what you're calling the
stipend I guess
I would have let me just get to one
piece page 186.
um yes that is what we're talking about
so that is not for that's obviously not
monthly that's that's kind of ballooned
out
okay so this is more like a thousand a
month eleven thousand
nine hundred seventy and you said 750
that's what they currently get oh I see
so this budget is requesting that they
that they get an increase gotcha okay
thank you sure
thank you Mr chair uh just a question uh
in regard to the number of positions
sure on the budget here it says six but
in your uh your presentation it seems
like there's only three people or or
less uh note there is there are six
official positions five of which is the
council members so there's officially
the five executive counselors and then
there's myself
and then the part-time person
um
is it's not an official part-time
position like because there's no uh
benefits associated with it thank you
for the clarification sure
doesn't have evil thanks so just to
clarify again on the stipend that covers
mileage and everything they don't get
anything additional this is like total
or correct they they do they do get a
wage but that is this is for to cover
any expenses as far as travel any
mailings that they do
from home
remind me what the wages
it's just over 17
000. it's per it's in
I could look up the RSA and tell you
because it's in the it's rsa941a
so just to follow up I'm looking at your
prioritized need and it says executive
Council stipend increase just for
district one but this is all inclusive
right uh yes yes
uh yes representative yes thanks thanks
Mr chair
um the stipend is that an automatic
thing or do they have to show receipts
of any kind it is an automatic thing
um again because in the past it was a
receipt based and there was so many
travel receipts being put forward it
became so cumbersome and so
foreign
yes you can continue sorry for the
interruption nope quite all right so
um
the other one of the other
prioritized needs that we are asking for
is a request to increase the funding for
our part-time office assistant which is
the person that serves with me for the
council right now we have been very
blessed to have with us Joanne rule who
was the executive assistant before me
and also was my boss when I was the
part-time assistant so it's interesting
that we have traded roles
her institutional knowledge and her
demeanor has been greatly appreciated
but she would like to officially retire
sadly
and work and we've been working with her
to you know pair back the time that
she's here
um but as as I'm sure you know from many
of your other hearings that you've done
and maybe even in your personal lives
we're in a very interesting and
challenging hiring climate right now and
it is a part-time position that does not
offer any benefits and so I'm trying to
make sure that I can be a little bit
competitive in an hourly rate that I can
offer someone the importance being that
we have office coverage for example this
morning as I was pan in a perfectly
great mood coming here uh I got a phone
call at the office from a constituent
who needed
um
some assistance and and an ear and I was
like oh Lord I do not have a lot of time
and so I I was thinking man if I had
somebody else here today that would be
fantastic but um having that office
coverage is important having someone to
be there if I'm out ill having someone
that actually can learn the office
state government is nuanced and
especially when you're working for an
office where people are elected
officials because it changes I think the
needs of the counselors change as the
council itself changes
and having someone that can come in and
learn those ropes and assist will allow
us to make sure that we are serving the
state properly and serving the
counselors properly
um the last is
the increases for doit
um and I know I mean I just heard the
testimony of the board before me and I
know that these numbers aren't
necessarily large when we're talking
overall but they're very important to us
we don't have a ton of overhead but what
we do have it's important for us to be
able to maintain
and and keep up with so we have systems
that are working incompatible with other
agencies and other offices
so being able to
have their support doit support and have
them come and work with us on upgrading
our computers when needed or the tablets
for the counselors
as those have to be done I think we try
to do that every other year some like
there's either a new uh printer or a new
copier or a new tablet like a group of
tablets for the counselors so that's
that's basically where that comes from
their Rising costs that they've that
they they have to pass on and then the
needs that we have to
um to meet what our office function is
so what our our calendar year recap I
think is just kind of a
an interesting blip of what we're
talking about the the governor in and
Council approve
a significant portion of approximately
six the approximate 6.5 billion dollars
that is appropriated annually by the
legislature the amount of money that
passes through the council to review and
then either is approved or not
um is quite remarkable and very and
unique to the state of New Hampshire
solely
um there were 322 confirmations for
boards and commissions approved
including Circuit Court judges a
superior court judge and commissioners
of this for the State of New Hampshire
of which 10 public hearings were held
and they're typically held right at the
State House at the executive council
chambers
um obviously we did what everybody else
did for covid and we we held them where
we could in venues that fit
um but it's nice to be back at the State
House doing that again
um and then the gas at work that they do
was approved by the legislature and
Governor this past calendar year and
I would have loved to have been able to
provide like one round number for you
but there's so much money that flows
through
um that that's sent to prioritized
infrastructure projects especially one
of the numbers that sticks out is like
242 million dollars went to Bridges just
Bridges across the state but there's
more details you can access that from
our website you can access it from Dot
and it's very interesting because they
go right out into the public into their
districts and they hold public hearings
and they take input from the towns and
the town's people and then all of that
comes together and they work very
diligently with DOT to put that together
for everyone's review
that is pretty much the snapshot of our
office and I'm happy to answer any other
questions
for Miss Rose yes representative Sweeney
thank you Mr chair thank you so much for
being here certainly when the executive
Council goes on the road
who pays the venue fee I'm not seeing a
line in the budget for that how does
that how does it dealt with if you're
renting an auditorium or so
the governor and Council when we take
the show on the road
um
it's basically we are the host
the host allows us the privilege to come
and do the state's work wherever it is
that we're going
um you'll see oftentimes we're at like
State Park venues
um or town venues and any costs
associated with that is basically it's
kind of like a donation type type thing
where people are just like here we will
allow you to utilize our space to
conduct your business
so there is no line item for that thank
you
for other questions I I'll go go ahead
the benefits line 60 is that strictly
for you or is that include some kind of
benefits for the counselor
um I believe that's that covers me but
um I know that the council does have an
option and they work directly with
um
with the benefits team where they can
they can like Buy in or um it's health
insurance yes health insurance but we do
right so we pay 100 and I assume yeah
they they do that it's a similar type
thing thank you yes
so I have a question to stipend there's
a differential between district one and
the others but looking at your map
District 2 now is almost identical to
District One
square mileage Town wise so was there
any consideration of upping the district
too since as we used to refer to as a
ray Burton District which included like
half the state but now it has been
modified quite a bit yes so actually
that was modified so if in that line
that page I think you said 186 that we
were looking at before so
um
you'll notice that there are two items
where they increase it says 11 970.
that's district one 11970 district 2. oh
I didn't see that yep and then the other
three districts which and if you go to
the map in the in the booklet that I
just gave you like district one and
District Two now are like 10 Towns
cities off from each other and they're
like
I don't know a couple hundred square
miles off from each other so
all right thanks so I guess we have to
ask yourselves do they deserve a raise
or what do you think representative
McGuire
yeah
this is a category where there's no
right answer right I mean these are
people
I'm sure they're paid much less than any
other elected official of similar
stature anywhere else in the country
just as we are right so there's no right
answer for for what they should be paid
it's just a
you know the only state that has
well there's three sure but I mean
you're talking about somebody
who's elected to one-fifth of a state
right so
you know what's such a person worth
there's no right answer to that right
but but I think I understand it at least
so the 89 700 that's their salary so
it's roughly 17
000 a piece right correct uh or eighteen
thousand a piece and then where you see
this line Tran in-state reimbursement
for transportation on the second page
line 70 that's this Transportation
stipend which districts one and two get
a little bigger than districts three
four and five
so total they're getting roughly
you know call it ten thousand from that
line and and uh 16 or 17th whatever
eighteen thousand from the other line so
their total compensation is roughly a
little under 30.
um
you know that doesn't seem unreasonable
like it's like
uh any further
questions
seeing none I guess you can report back
to the counselors that they might get an
increase Fair let's let's hope they're
listening
thank you very much you're welcome
so my guess is that we probably don't
need to see the executive Council unless
we find something
where we get a call from one of the
councils asking for more money perhaps
all right thanks
thank you very much
so good morning uh good afternoon rather
it's a little slow here on the take-up
uh liquor is next this is found on page
325 or something like that yep 325.
so it's all yours I know there are a few
questions when you're done so thanks
absolutely thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee good afternoon
I'm Joseph Malika I'm the chairman of
the New Hampshire Liquor Commission and
with me is Tina demirs our CFO
so we're here today to go through our FY
2425 budget and Tina is the budget
expert and the main Marquee of this so I
will let her take it away and we'll be
happy to answer questions when you're
done thank you very much
good afternoon
so if you open your presentation on page
two we've included the introduction it's
the same as we presented last week as a
reminder that the Liquor Commission is
self-funded and our primary statutory
Duties are to optimize profits and
maintain controls through effective and
efficient operations while providing
service to customers all of which we
take very seriously the budget we've
prepared and are presenting is the level
of funding necessary to accomplish these
legislative duties which are RSA
176 3.
on page three
are the sales and revenue projections
that support the budget requesting since
we are self-funded this is similar to
what we provided last week except for we
added the teal columns for the
Governor's recommended budget with FY 23
24 and 25 liquor estimates at 135
million in FY 24 and 25 the total
expenses we included an estimate for the
10 and the 2 percent raise to show the
impact to the net revenue
so into the budget on page four is a
listing of our major expense categories
that correspond to the table and the
line numbers that we've identified on
page five
so I won't read through all the
categories but there are a couple of um
that we think are important to highlight
the first is number one salaries and
benefits they're decreasing in FY 24
even though with the requested 28 new
positions and this is because of a
reduction in the overtime and part-time
budget requests and the changes in
positions as a result of turnover
fy25 increases are a result of salary
steps and benefit increases
the next one to highlight is number six
technology it's increasing for our
additional prioritized needs request for
subscriptions and existing support and
maintenance contracts to support our
next-gen d365 software platform and
that's to replace our current point of
sale and back office Financial system
number seven is our doit increase for
additional prioritized needs it's also
to support the d365 software platform
the governor's budget only included 500
000 each year of the million dollar
request and this was for the Azure
hosting services and liquor share of the
increased shared services the unfunded
doit requests are for two new positions
uh handheld devices and cloud services
all of which are important to support
the new d365 software platform so we
feel these items could be added back to
our budget without impacting the bottom
line revenue
the increases related to the new system
are significant and that's because we've
been running the same course system for
the last 40 years which has been
supported primarily by in-house staff so
moving to a current technology requires
a lot more licensing and cloud storage
versus our current server and backup
storage that we're doing
so on
oops and I just want to say yes you did
hear Tina correctly The Liquor
Commission is running on a 40 year old
platform
[Laughter]
pretty close
uh on page six is a listing of all of
our additional prioritized needs that we
had in our agency submitted budget the
items in green are the ones that are
included in the governor's budget
on page seven and eight these show the
annual breakdown by class and accounting
unit you'll see the breakdown is
consistent for both years for class and
accounting unit the fy24 efficiency
budget is 2.4 million or 2.9 percent
more than our FY 23 adjusted authorized
budget plus a 3.3 million increase for
the additional prioritized needs for a
total increase of 6.9 percent or 5.7
million
salary benefits and traveler decreasing
while the other categories are
increasing due to the cost of inflation
and projected needs such as utilities
equipment Dent debt rent and contracts
on page eight is the FY 25 total budget
which is increasing 3.1 million or 3.5
percent over fy24 total budget and
that's for again for salary step
increases and benefits and for the same
cost of inflation and projected needs as
fy24
um
on page nine is our organizational
structure as we presented it last week
I'll just point out the new positions
requested in red we have two in audit
and inventory control section and that's
for an accountant and an additional
internal auditor which is based on a
recommendation from a prior audit report
the other positions are under marketing
and Merchandising two are in marketing
for an additional beverage marketing
specialist and a program specialist for
data research and Analysis and then we
have the 24 new store clerk positions
for various retail outlets to meet the
needs of customers process transactions
and manage inventory
on page 10 we've provided so before we
move too far away from the numbers okay
I did have a couple of questions and
anyone else that may have some questions
so I'm looking at the governor's
proposal that we received the other day
for actual monies transferred to the
general fund it was like 140 million
dollars according to his numbers
but I see under the Trends on page three
for actuals for
two
it's a hundred and thirty three million
and you're a number so I just kind of
curious about the discrepancy there
because it shows actuals for 21
transfer to General fundance of 148 and
133 and like I said the governor shows
the actuals of
140 million so I just wondering which
I'm sorry which page are you on I'm on
page three no if the governor's uh page
15.
General funds education funds under
restricted Revenue transferred from The
Liquor Commission
so page 15.
you're the executive summary yeah
okay so back to our page sorry
so you're looking at FY 22 yeah and
you're line 10 on page three
that's um if you look look at the
revenue based on plan of the
141.8 including that's where the
confusion lies with the transfer the
additional transfers to the alcohol fund
okay
I'm not quite seeing it yet but I'm sure
I'll find it right line 12. I see that
yeah
but there's still the numbers the
actuals are still different
anyway we can figure that so I can I can
look back at that and get back to you on
what the difference would be oh yeah
yeah all right and as long as we're a
numbers the governor also said that he
was looking to transfer about 14 million
dollars out of the rainy day fund to a
new liquor store
for Hampton I'm just curious why we
wouldn't take it out of the liquor line
versus taking it out of the rainy day
fund
currently we have a capital
appropriation for the Hampton projects
and we've put in a requests for
additional funds for the increased costs
um the only thing that I can think of is
if we sold the property that would be
paying off our debt but we didn't
request additional rainy day funds for
the Hampton properties we were funding
that through our Capital appropriation
okay
we'll look at that too because it looks
a little different I saw that too and I
wasn't sure what that was okay
um and just one more question going on
to page five where the debt service is
going to be increasing to about 15.4
percent this is on
other expenses down near the lower part
of the middle of page five I just
curious increasing it by 15.4 percent
seems pretty substantial to me
and that's for the additional funds for
the Hampton property we put in 7 million
but it looks like the governor's Capital
put in 13 million so we have to clarify
that one too because we were rolling
forward the original appropriation for
Hampton we brought that balance forward
and then we were asking for additional
funds for the cost of construction
increases but when I looked at the
capital request it looks like we're
getting an additional 14 million so I
have to clarify that one too okay we
just haven't had a chance to reach out
yet all right I just you know as long as
we were on the numbers you didn't want
to go too far yes you have a tendency to
forget some of my questions
um are there any other questions at
least on the numbers portion before we
move into the deeper part of the
presentation
seeing none will move right along
okay so
um page 10 we provided this last week
which was a history of positions except
for this time we just added 24 and 25 to
show the additional positions which give
us a total positions of 371.
on page 11 through 15 our summary by
division as listed in the governor's
budget book with page references the
numbers we're presenting though are
based on our agency's submitted request
um there are party charts on each
showing the breakdown by class category
and an explanation uh for the changes
first is the office of the Commissioners
overseeing all operations of the
commission with the primary goal to
increase sales and maximize profits
while operating in a cost-effective and
efficient manner
the one item to note is the increase in
FY 24 of 307
000 which is to add a consultant line to
support the doit with the next-gen
system and this is for individual
specific technical skill sets that might
be needed
fy25 increases for salary steps and
benefits and increased costs to support
headquarters
on page 12 as the division of
enforcement and this includes
enforcement licensing education and
grants the division is responsible for
enforcing alcoholic beverages laws
enforcing youth access to liquor and
tobacco and providing licensing
education and support for over 6 100
licensees in FY 22 the division
collected over our 19 million in Revenue
FY 24 budget is decreasing 6.6 percent
due to changes in positions as a result
of turnover and is increasing in FY 25
for salary and steps and benefits
on page 13 we have the division of
administration which includes doit HR
and finance
this includes audit and inventory
control in our legal unit and these all
Provide support to the all departments
within the commission
fy24 increase of 20 or 1.7 million is
primarily for that additional
prioritized needs for doit along with
adding an allocation for indirect cost
and the two new positions and then fy25
is increasing as the others for salary
steps and benefits
on page 14 the division of marketing and
Merchandising includes marketing and
Merchandising advertising retail store
outlets and the headquarters Warehouse
the division oversees the buying
marketing selling and distributing of
products through all of our channels to
promote sales and maximize profits
fy24 increase of 5.2 percent or 3.5
million is in large part from the
increase in technology and hardware and
software for the additional prioritized
needs for the next gen system and
continuing operations for contracts debt
rent equipment supplies and utilities
our fy25 3.9 percent or 2.7 million
increase is mainly for the salary steps
and benefits and the increased cost of
doing business in areas such as metal
shelving for the stores supplies
utilities and rent
um
page 15 workers comp and unemployment
comp workers comp for FY 23 is
underfunded and the increase in FY 24 is
based on historical Trend the increase
is because as we continue to be
understaffed and ask more of our
employees we are seeing a higher claims
and then the last two pages 16 and 17
this is the house bill 2 language that
we provided last week to give us the
authority to transfer funds out of
additional profits for the outlet
employees incentive program
and we would be happy to answer any more
questions
represent Maguire
thank you Mr chairman thank you guys for
coming
um so in a number of areas I see
salaries decrease in fiscal year 24 but
increase in 25 which doesn't make sense
to me because 24 is the year of the 10
increase and 25 is only a 2 percent
increase
we did not include in our agency numbers
the 10 in the two percent increase these
numbers were based on what we originally
submitted um we actually in the
governor's phase we didn't have an
increase in any of those class lines
either
hmm
so what's actually in here in the
governor's budget is it with the 10
increase no no
because you're separate or it would
happen it's just not it I I don't know
it they weren't calculated into the
expense numbers in these two
Appropriations
Mike wants to come with yeah I
understand that the 10 increase is go
going to be in the trailer bill
a separate appropriation in the trailer
bill
but I thought in some of these cases we
were seeing it already in this book no
no
from the earlier eight no okay
I thought we were told that yeah yeah
we're gonna have to we have to dig into
that a little bit Yeah the numbers
didn't change from when we submitted it
for the agency phase to the governor's
face so that's why on page three
we included it in the overall total for
our total expenses to be able to show
how we come down to that net profit
number of 135 million we're anticipating
that that 10 and 2 percent will be about
3.5 million to a 4 million in 24 and 25.
further question yes
so
okay so then when when you're having
decreases in 24 that's is that layoffs
is that no it's due to turnover so as
you have people that are uh leaving that
are at a higher step in labor grade and
you're being replaced by somebody at a
lower step
that's primarily gotcha are you planning
so when you're getting these 10
increases is are you planning to give
them to everybody including part-time
um we're not giving them it's for
full-time employees to 10 okay
thank you
representative Sweeney thank you
chairman thank you both for being here
um I am intrigued by the employee
incentive program and I just have a
question on obviously it's largely for
what the public sees a retail business
right um and so your competitors for
hiring are the Walmart's Market Basket
those stores are you able or in this
budget proposal or do you have what you
would need to stay competitive in the
hiring process with those other
companies that are moving up their pay
well as we stated in our overview last
week representative we we feel that our
employees are underpaid grossly
underpaid quite frankly and
um given the uh
the numbers that are out there in the
retail environment between our incentive
program and the 10 percent increase that
will certainly help us in hiring more
employees but we were down we are down
84 full-time equivalent employees
between full-time and part-time and have
been even deeper down
uh and and we're starting to see some of
the hiring take place will we be equal
to no we won't be
so
follow up thank you what's the current
rate for an hourly worker it starts
starts at 12.63 an hour
thank you you're welcome
so obviously uh we're always looking or
the state's always looking for the most
money out of you folks I know it's a a
tough job
that you have to provide the funds is
that I think you had 135 million or
something
coming back to the general fund
somewhere is that doable I know there's
been a decline in revenues as of late
we certainly think it's doable yes we uh
you know our sales we're meeting plan
we're we're meeting the plan that we've
put forward so uh our sales have
certainly declined for a number of
reasons that we went over in the primer
last week uh you know obviously the main
reason being competition from
Massachusetts but we're meeting our plan
and we're competent with our numbers
see on page three we are projecting
increasing our sales if you look at
column M line one our net sales based on
those 24 new positions we're increasing
our sales by 32 million because we have
we have a full-time equivalent of about
a million dollars annually that um a
full-time employee produces in the
stores
so that was added into the budget as
added into the revenue as our
projections with those positions in
place
okay represent Griffin
I personally am a little concerned about
the economy going into a tailspin
or at least a mild recession
you must have a history of
sales numbers that happen when when the
economy softens what is that history and
is it likely to repeat itself if we have
a
softening of the market well uh having
been in the alcohol beverage business
for over 40 years I can certainly tell
you that uh in in Good Times people
drink and in bad times people drink more
and our sales are our sales across the
board as long as we don't see that our
seals will decrease given that people
are still coming to New Hampshire and
they're still vacationing here as we all
know 50 percent of our business comes
from across the border if so if our
state for some reason becomes less
inviting to folks or there's reasons why
they don't travel here that would be the
only thing that would infect our
business but we don't see that happening
thank you thank you representative
here's a follow-up to representative
Griffin's question I think a few years
back you gave us a 10-year run from what
it was actually provided to the general
fund I don't know if you could put
something like that together which would
include some of those difficult years I
think is a good question from
happy to do that
representative McGuire so during the
pandemic was there less travel and
therefore less sales or no no quite
quite the contrary oh people were people
were home people were working from home
and sales spiked maybe less sales to
relatively Less sales to out-of-state
it it seemed that there was there was a
little less but I think people that were
traveling what we saw and I think the
real estate market will will uh
will support is that so many people
moved to New Hampshire during that
period of time a lot of people moved
here I mean you know there was a number
of homes for sale in the North country
that are no longer for sale people came
here people bought homes that lifted our
boat
yeah just in general I mean this is a
fantastic business right you're you're
spending 75 million dollars and taking
in
215 or something like that right I mean
it's
[Laughter]
it's no wonder that that somebody can
can compete right because they don't
need that kind of profit margin I think
right well I I think that the state has
been has been very gifted with this
business since since prohibition and
we've continued to make it profitable
and have you know quite frankly doubled
business in the last 15 years so uh
We've created a brand that people now
recognize uh and that's something that
is the state can be proud of
okay thank you thank you representative
thank you Mr chairman
so for my own curiosity can you produce
the Delta between what you're paying
retails now and what you believe the pay
should be for the most competitive to
fill the vacancies so that the stores
are fully staffed
what would that pay per hour look like
and what would that budget line need to
be well I I think the the pay one of the
things that we had requested in House
Bill 2 uh that was taken out was on a
was some language that allowed us to
compensate our retail store employees
only just the people out in the outlets
with an average wage that was
competitive with uh retailers in the
state and that would probably be
something that as we know would would
fluctuate I think that obviously I find
I'm I don't not going to do the math
here but I would think we would have to
be somewhere
in the 1650 to 18 an hour range to
compete across the board in the state
with that's starting wage part-time
employees
thank you you're welcome
foreign
further questions yes represent
kimbrells thank you Mr chair you
mentioned earlier that uh adding a new
employee is tantamount to increasing the
business by about a million dollars
um would that also require that a new
store be open or by simply adding 28 new
people to the existing stores you you
predict you to have another million
dollars in sales per person correct
because right now we were not able to
open our stores for the additional hours
for the holidays and for seasonal we had
to reduce hours and we had to clearly
had to close stores so this would get us
back up to the Staffing level that we
need to really run the stores more
profitably thank you
further questions I do have one on
workman's comp I saw that was up by like
86 or something percent do you work with
the Department of administrative
Services as far as your insurance I
should know this but I or do you have
your own workman's comp carrier and you
know we work with risk management
history risk management and our HR
department it is starting to go down
because our HR department has been
working very closely with the insurance
company on looking into the the cases
all right thank you and a new insurance
company as well
yeah all right thank you
representative McGuire so our most
claims based on you know bad backs and
things like that from lifting and
absolute that kind of thing yes okay now
you asked for you told you said that you
would ask the governor for a couple of
specialized positions that weren't
granted
right and and you thought you could put
them in with no effect on the bottom
line correct part of the additional
prioritized needs for doit
they have the two positions yes and we
think we could bring back that 500 000
of additional prioritized needs in doit
and not have a bottom line impact
do you want to more detail about what
those people would do and
well they're technical technical support
people so one of them
um is a technical support specialist
actually both of them are ones for
Enterprise architect and it all has to
do with our new next-gen system to help
support so that they can get
specialized training and and be targeted
to that because right now we have the
two people that are running our current
system and we don't want to be in the
same situation of you know having more
people that understand the new system
one of the things representative and and
not to belabor the point but a 40 year
old system that's been run internally by
The Liquor Commission for all these
years we're now going to d365 so
obviously at The Liquor Commission and
in the state there's not a lot of people
that have the wherewithal to run a
system like that and have that sort of
uh education and background so we're
looking to go out and hire those people
so we can make sure that 35 years from
now when someone else redoes the system
that they won't have to go through the
same things that we're going through now
so are you saying that if you don't have
these people they would be replaced by
Consultants or something like that is I
I think if we don't hire these people
that we would have to look outside to
hire people through CSI which is a
company that doit uses to to find
somebody of that caliber to help us as
we move to the new program to the new
platform and the maintenance of the new
platform as well
so you're essentially going to be
expending similar amounts of money
whether they're your own employee or
elsewhere yeah that would that's correct
okay
tomato tomato if
any questions over there representative
Hewitt you okay
representative hatch
okay
so it looks like we're in pretty good
shape so we're just looking for that
10-year history
and I guess you're going to check on the
general funds differences in the 14
million whether that's coming out of the
rainy day fund or
Capital fund or whatever yes
yes and I don't think we need to have
you back if you could just get those
items to the LBA that would be perfect
absolutely thank you very much thank you
very much thank you all
we should ask Gary why he said
I'm sorry commissioner is it possible
you could get something even from the
budget director why they didn't support
your two requests
for the technical positions to technical
positions thank you thanks
one more item for you uh Mr Hoffman to
add to the list
well that went quicker than I thought it
should but yeah because the way he
explains it
yeah yeah
all right so now you can run to tandy's
or wherever for half an hour
so we could still certainly talk about
that okay maybe we could get data about
how projects are sized I mean I don't
know
is it
I mean obviously a hundred thousand
square foot building versus a single
family home
work
we're still technically supposed to um
if we're discussing policy what's that
it should be on or off on okay all right
well in that case so so this is a tax
appeal right so so somebody said your
property your property value is X and
you say no it isn't it's why right
that's that's the appeal right yeah so
so there is a number there
so you could
yeah I mean so you could say
you know you could step it or you could
do a percentage or you could do I mean
there's lots of ways you could do it
well Dan makes a good point because if
you go to Des and you're disturbing like
a hundred thousand square feet you have
to get a site specific permit but
anything under that you don't but maybe
in this case if you've got a commercial
development maybe this should be a
higher fee even for a residential or
so you have some ideas we can put it in
the yeah I mean there are up to a
million it's the 65 and over that it's
yeah you know a tenth of a percent or
something or whatever it is somebody
might have a five five thousand dollar
difference that they're appealing and
others may have two million yeah that's
true and and it also that actually would
make sense because it would have to be
more complicated to do an appeal of a
much larger amount for a commercial
developer so you could track it to the
what it cost you want to put something
together
oh all right does the position have to
be self-funded from their fees or how
how are the rest of their budgets
it's mostly General it's mostly General
so what prohibits I know they've tried
to put in for another employee
um is that something that was within our
realm to say hey they need another
employee and provide the general funds
for it sure yeah we can do any actually
in anything we want okay we write the
law right because as opposed to I know
that at the end of the day the taxpayer
pays for it but as opposed to saying hey
let's increase fees everybody hates that
you just appropriate it because it's
needed it's a position and we give them
the general funds for it well you raise
a good point like the taxpayer pays for
it but the taxpayer is paying for
something that is really patently and
unfair because if you're only paying 65
the other taxpayers have to pick up the
cost of running that agency
but in in general we don't charge a lot
for judges and things like that right
Justice is supposed to be part of the
cost of General government right so you
don't you don't make fees like like in
order to go to court it costs you ten
twenty thousand dollars or something of
a fee right you know
so so you don't want to make it too bad
but on the other hand
you a little some kind of a fee
discourages
frivolous uh activity right so there's
there's some balance there right so yeah
I have a
I have a lot of background at the Board
of tax and land appeals because I was a
selectman
15 years
and we were kind of regulars there
to the extent that they told us they
didn't know didn't ever want to see us
again
we should settle cases at home
but the idea of the idea of the board of
tax and landed Fields is I understand
that is to keep people from going to
Superior Court
and so it should be free really
it should be encouraged to use that
use that facility rather than go to
court well the fee is a little bit too
maybe uh stem abuse of it too I mean
that there's a balance there so let me
know well and it's much more expensive
to go to Superior Court overall than it
is about so
now when people go to the they have to
land a building they go with a lawyer no
not typically no well she said some Pro
Se and some maybe not
probably probably depends on how much
how much the difference differential
with your experience they make Fair
my my experience was very positive there
really but you know I I usually think
they focus in on the on the facts at
least as Lisa and we didn't always win
but
uh it it worked very efficiently I don't
know whether it still does or not
because it's been years now since I've
been there but when we were using it it
worked very very well well it's got to
be efficient well I'm going to say
adjudicate yeah with very few resources
right and they hadn't raised the fee
since 77. yeah so if you think even of
inflation
yeah didn't you come up representative
Sweeney with sounds like 300 yeah it was
uh on my phone earlier it was
65.77 is 360 uh
360.25 today that's not a proposal I'm
just interesting right
okay
so representative McGuire do you want to
come up with something for us to beat
around that'll be great
all right so we'll take a short recess
good discussion
all right
foreign
so we'll open up the uh work session
for the Department of Employment
Security
and this is on page 535 it starts and
another one of those agencies I don't
believe you take any of our general
funds right yeah
yes you stole my thunder we are very
proud to be able to sit here and tell
you that we have zero General funds
um usually it doesn't allow us to stand
up and walk out but
quick take advantage of that
well if you could roll introduce
yourself and if your last name is
difficult to spell
it for our clerk thanks uh Rich lavers
l-a-v-e-r-s I'm the Deputy Commissioner
with the Department
Rebels r-e-v-e-l-s I'm the business
administ
ration and uh apologies for uh
commissioner capatus George was
unexpectedly ill today nothing to do
with all of you more to do with spending
spending time with his grandchildren and
what they bring home from school but
um he unfortunately was not able to make
it here today
um so we did have a narrative that we
had uh provided
um where on page I believe 535 on the
the governor's recommended budget
um we can do an abbreviated uh version
of of the narrative or we can go right
into questions or particular issues that
um the members would like to discuss
um however you'd like to do that
while you've gone to the effort of
putting this together so uh you should
take us through it thank you
um so
our 24 25 budget
provides a sufficient level of funding
so that we'll continue to be able to
provide exceptional service in our our
core programs
um
we have zero General funds in the agency
so we are federally funded and other
funds those other funds are a mixture of
both
unemployment insurance tax payments from
employers and income received from other
agencies and organizations for services
that we provide to them but zero General
funds
the um
portion of the unemployment insurance
tax payments from employers the The
Lion's Share of that payment from
employers does go into the unemployment
compensation trust fund from which
benefits are paid
um and there is a administrative
contribution that is set aside from that
from each quarterly payment that
supports a portion of the operational
costs of the department
percentage on that assessment it's the
administrative contribution is point
four percent right now and that was
recently increased uh two budgets ago
correct
irrespective of the unemployment rate
the employee employer uh pays correct so
the
um the first point four percent
um paid by an employer goes towards the
administrative contribution
um and then
um there are the rest of that goes to
the unemployment compensation trust fund
and that the rate at which they pay is
based upon experience with the
unemployment system thank you
is that point four percent of salary or
point four percent of what they pay into
the system
um so it's point so the the way that
their tax rate is set is it's easiest to
to look at a new employer so a new
employer registers and they come in with
a 2.7 tax rate set for their first four
quarters and that's 2.7 paid on the
first fourteen thousand dollars in
annual wages for each employee
um so the the point four
um is similarly applicable it goes on
the 0.4 of that first fourteen thousand
dollars in annual wages paid each
employee employers largely pay most of
that that UI tax is associated with
wages paid in the first quarter
um with some coming in from the second
quarter and then your seasonal
businesses uh pay an associate
association with whatever season their
their work their work Workforce is heavy
so you're saying they're paying 3.1
percent on that 14 000 no no they're
they're two it's 2.7 but the the 0.4 of
that goes to the administrative contract
and 2.3 goes into the phone correct I
see yeah okay thank you
um high level of our budget it's very
much uh Personnel heavy
um with about 60 of our budget
um that is in order to
um
be able to successfully administer our
core programs both the unemployment
insurance program so not only the
um adjudication of unemployment claims
and
um the appeals that could uh follow from
that and having the staff associated
with being able to implement that timely
and successfully but also the New
Hampshire Works One-Stop centers that
are located throughout the state we
operate those centers
um uh with both our staff partner agency
staff
um so
um our budget's about 60 percent uh
Personnel costs we have another 23
percent of our budget that is I.T
related
uh both for the uh services that we
receive from doit we have uh 17
embedded doit staff that actually sit
over with uh with Employment Security
they are providing
um a hundred percent of their time to
the department and then we have some
shared service costs with doit we also
have support and maintenance related
costs for the
software and Hardware from which the
unemployment program is run along with
our job match system
and Associated
software and technology that makes those
systems operational so very much I.T
dependent from a staffing perspective so
we have 293 authorized positions in the
24-25 budget plus another 26 temporary
positions
currently we have 262 filled positions
and 55 positions that are vacant so
um just looking at the 55 vacant that
would be about a 17 vacancy rate however
only 27 of those positions are an active
recruitment right now so it's about a
nine percent vacancy rate the other
positions that are that are budgeted for
that are not an active recruitment that
are vacant that is how we have
historically
approached each budget cycle so that
we're ready and can increase our
staffing as needed in order to respond
to an economic downturn so
um as the economy goes through Cycles
every seven years or so we encounter a
downturn that really increases our level
of service we need to provide to the
public not only from an Unemployment
Compensation Program perspective but all
of those One-Stop centers
then need to have the Staffing in order
to be able to
um provide services to the individuals
that are coming in so that's what we're
looking at right now for Staffing as
we'd indicated before there are no
General funds associated with our budget
we are
federally funded through grants
associated with the programs that we
administer the largest of those is the
unemployment insurance program grants
then we have an assortment of grants for
programs that we administer in
partnership with the Bureau of Labor
Statistics for our economic and labor
market information group
and our re-employment programs as well
so programs that staff administer out in
those One-Stop centers assisting
individuals connect with hiring
employers or connecting with training
opportunities and those are our federal
grants that we receive
and then the other other agency income
that we receive is for an assortment of
services that we provide
to other agencies having to do in some
instances with data that we were able to
provide to them
um an example of that is with
a partnership with business and economic
Affairs where we actually provide the
qualitative data on looking at how
people that have completed training
through federally funded wioa funded
programs how well they are doing after
that training how quickly they find
employment we we thought we provide that
data and then we also have an assortment
of services in conjunction with Health
and Human Services on looking and
Reporting on new hires to assist with
child support enforcement and things of
that nature
so
um with that all being said we can
certainly get into some details on any
of areas of the recommended budget that
the committee would like to talk about
representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman
so let's go to page 536
um
is
line 102 what was training and that's
becoming 72 and 73 or something like
that
yeah
that is correct Jill do you want to talk
a little bit about that
um payments as well as dislocated worker
payments that we administered that
program under mou with Bea we were told
that OneNote class 102 was please
explain acceptable
memorandum of understanding with uh
Department of Business
Affairs we have an agreement with them
where we administer the dislocated
worker program
um oh okay so the the disloc the
dislocated worker program is one of the
programs that's under the
um federally funded uh Workforce
Innovation Opportunity Act wioa programs
so Bea business and economic Affairs
they are the administrative Agency for
those wioa programs for the state they
then through the memorandum of
understanding designate Employment
Security to both be the One-Stop
operator for the the
12 offices throughout the state the New
Hampshire Works offices where those
programs get delivered out of and we
administer the dislocated worker program
so that is Staff in those one stops that
works with individuals recently
unemployed connecting them with training
operations because you're connected with
unemployed like people it's a yeah I see
so it's a you know as individuals file
uh for benefits they then get invited in
for an assortment of uh workshops and
one-on-one sessions with our staff at
which time uh we're then able to make
them aware of the various programs that
we have that can help connect them with
training and help connect them with
hiring employers and dislocated work the
dislocated worker program that's
federally funded and comes through Bea
is one of those programs
okay
thank you so revolving funds that must
be this 2.7 percent yes okay correct why
is there a big jump of about 3 million
from last biennium to this one
um the the anticipated increase
um in the increase that we've been
seeing in the the administrative
contribution funds
um largely driven by the additional
employers that have registered in the
State uh since going back to
if we go back to the first quarter of
2020 to compare where we currently are
we've added about 9 000 employers
um to the state so it's about a 20
increase those employers then contribute
both to with the administrative
contribution and they contribute as well
to the unemployment trust fund which is
back up
um about 60 million above where it was
prior to the pandemic so we started the
pandemic with about 310 million dollars
in the unemployment trust fund and we
have about 360 million dollars in that
fund now so that increase employers both
drives up the trust fund out of which
benefits are paid in the administrative
contribution that provides support to
the Department
do you start to lower the 2.4 percent
when the fund gets to some level
um yeah so the the solvency controls for
the the trust fund are are built in
statute so the way it's done differently
in each state
um New Hampshire
um the solvency controls are determined
by the balance in the trust fund so
um at uh 250 million dollars if the
trust fund is able to maintain that for
an entire quarter employers then the
next quarter receive a 0.5 percent
reduction to their tax rates so that 2.7
percent new employer would go down to
2.2 percent
if the fund maintains 350 million
dollars for an entire quarter those
employers get a one percent reduction to
their rate and then when the fund
maintains 400 million those employers
get a 1.5 percent reduction to their tax
rates so that 1.5 is the maximum
reduction
um they are those thresholds are
determined to be the levels at which the
fund can afford to slow down its growth
and to stop its growth
when when we look at trust fund solvency
New Hampshire like all other states we
get graded by the U.S Department of
Labor each year prior to the the
pandemic we were considered to have a
solvent trust fund
um last report that came out in April of
last year we were not and that was
largely because of the pandemic
we have since that time seen explosive
growth in the unemployment compensation
trust fund at the time of our last
solvency score I think the fund was at
190 million dollars we're now at 360. so
I anticipate that when the next report
comes out from the US Department of
Labor in April of this year that they'll
find New Hampshire to have a more
solvent trust fund than we even did
before uh before the pandemic but that's
how those how rates get lowered
um as a result of the balance and the
trust fund being determined sufficient
to support what
is anticipated to be the the next round
of
increased Demand on the on the benefit
system
our benefits to unemployed persons fixed
dollar amounts also in law or are they
no they are okay then correct okay yes
so
the
um weekly benefit amount is set by
Statute and it's tied to how much you
earned during the four quarters of your
base period so when when you file a
claim uh for unemployment you need two
things in order to be eligible one is
you need to have a qualifying separation
so you need to be unemployed through no
fault of your own most common situation
being a layoff but you also need to have
demonstrated a sufficient level of
attachment to the labor market labor to
the labor force and you need to have at
least twenty eight hundred dollars in
earnings during your four quarter base
period
um and that 2800 needs to be divided up
so it in at least two quarters you had
fourteen hundred dollars in earnings
then the once the the separation
um eligibility requirement is met in the
earning
um eligibility requirement is met we
then look at the statutory table to see
okay how much did you earn in those four
quarters and then that corresponds to a
weekly benefit amount that you are
eligible for for up to 26 weeks so for
example the highest weekly benefit
amount in New Hampshire is 427 dollars
um that corresponds corresponds to base
period earnings of forty one thousand
five hundred dollars
um it's been quite some time since that
has has been touched
um that 427 was added in 2007.
um uh but if you are earning 41.5 in
your base period 427 is your weekly
benefit amount if you're earning a
hundred thousand dollars in your base
period
um 427 is that amount you're eligible
for that for 26 weeks on average right
now
um people are collecting for 10 weeks
which is the fifth lowest duration in
the country
um we actually have the lowest
exhaustion rate in the country right now
about eight percent of people filing
actually use all of their weeks so less
than one in ten people use all the weeks
available
um
in order to access the benefits for all
those weeks you need to be able to work
available to work and you need to be
completing a work search with each
weekly claim that you file
okay thank you
you really know your stuff represents
Sweeney I think I saw you thank you Mr
chairman thank you both for being here
um line 18 in the budget for overtime uh
1.6 million in 2022 I imagine the 27
vacancies drove that overtime use and
we're just hoping that we fill those for
the future
yeah we
um it's a good uh line item to draw
attention to
um at the in the initial part of the the
pandemic because of all of the various
things that were going on and being in
the middle of a Public Health crisis we
weren't eight we we had to respond
overnight essentially
um and weren't able to staff up like we
would with a traditional recession that
you have a little bit more lead time
um to prepare for
um so we really leaned on our staff
quite heavily at one point I think was
in April of of 2020 we actually had
about 95 uh the equivalent in overtime
hours of 95 additional ftes
um our our people were
um uh uh living within the walls of our
buildings and providing Services
um we obviously with uh the the pandemic
related workloads uh coming down
um adjusting our staffing
um as appropriate
um that anticipated need as as
down significantly
but we we're able to we relied very
heavily upon our staff our existing
staff at the beginning of the pandemic
we're able to bring on some additional
staff to assist where the workload was
at each time whether it be in initial
claims or an appeals
um or in within the services that the
the local office the New Hampshire Works
One-Stop center staff were providing but
we think we're we're we're staffed
um uh very really well right now for the
the level of services we're providing
and if we were to need additional staff
then we do have the requested vacant
funded positions which we would then
fill hopefully we wouldn't need to do
things the way we did them back in in
2020 and having to ramp up our services
overnight thank you
representative evil thank you
[Music]
pandemic I just want to compliment
to help some constituents some relatives
and I I just don't even know how you did
what you did and there were a couple of
times I reached out to you and you got
things turned around and it's just I bet
you look back at it now and you can't
believe what you had to do I just
wondered so thank you very much I just
want to ask you do you have much problem
with employers paying into the fund what
they need to pay and if you do how do
you pursue something like that
um the the compliance rate for employers
is uh I don't I can um get you those
numbers but the compliance rate is
remarkably uh good in New Hampshire
um but we do have we do have those
employers that uh either through just
being unaware or um not understanding
the requirements in New Hampshire that
don't register
um and uh will occasionally uh receive a
claim for which we have no reported
wages
um and that that then triggers our tax
unit and our field staff uh that they
then have a conversation with that
employer get them registered make sure
that we're going uh back to the the
quarter in which they should have
registered with us get them in at the
appropriate tax rate and then for those
that are unable or uh that do not pay
their quarterly tax we do have a
Collections Unit that our Collections
Unit uh does pursue
employer tax debt they pursue that very
aggressively
um with an assortment of of collection
tools
um hopefully it can be managed with a
with a payment agreement with the
employer if they're unable to to pay
what they owe us at that time but we do
have more aggressive Tools in statute I
mean that unit also handles on
overpayment collection as well from
individuals that
um through
information that uh was material
materially inaccurate that they provided
to us that created eligibility and
they're found to not have been paid
correctly that Collections Unit also
pursues collection of those types of
debts as well
just before so what about the flip side
what about uh fraudulent claims do you
see much of that or you hear a lot about
that I wondered what the reality was
and um there is
with the the types of fraud that the
unemployment program has historically
experienced and and we continue to
experience historically it's been
earnings related fraud so individuals
who have a qualifying separation from
employment
um and they are they are rightfully
collecting go back to work and they they
don't feel the need to report the new
job and the earnings associated with
that new job to the department they
continue to collect benefits despite us
asking very clearly on that Weekly
application for benefits whether they
were working and whether they had any
earnings associated with work for those
folks we have a fraud investigative unit
and we have a relationship with the
Attorney General's office where we
actually fund a position that sits
within the Attorney General's office
criminal Bureau and they prosecute
unemployment fraud and that is their
sole responsibility uh so the earnings
fraud we take very seriously we go after
those individuals aggressively
um we try to
make sure that we can use that those
cases that are prosecuted as much of a
deterrent as possible when individuals
come in with a new claim and they sit
through one of our workshops we remind
them about their responsibilities and we
show them what happens when you don't
follow through with those
responsibilities so we try to do as much
so that we don't have those overpayments
coming out of the trust fund so that we
can keep those dollars in the trust fund
but it still happens
the pandemic though the fraud was
different the fraud that we experience
just like every other state although we
handled it differently than other states
the fraud was more identity theft
related fraud so it wasn't fraud being
committed by people here in New
Hampshire that through just the desire
to have their unemployment benefit plus
their new wages were failing to report
things to us these are
out of state out of country
organizations that were using previously
stolen identities
could be you know there are a a lot of
individuals that would be contacting us
throughout the throughout the the
pandemic asking us about having received
a notice saying but I've never filed a
claim what is this notice asking me
about the claim that I filed
um so that was
um multinational fraud Rings criminal
organizations that were using stolen
identities not information they stole
from Employment Security but they stole
through other means and then using it to
try to leverage and gain the
um the additional benefits that were
available during the pandemic there were
hundreds of millions of dollars paid out
nationally might even I haven't been
able to see a good solid number on that
but some states had a tremendous amount
of ID theft related fraud and their
trust funds suffered as a result of that
New Hampshire
we had about five hundred thousand
dollars in ID theft related fraud
payments out of the two billion dollars
that we paid out
um so most of that was in the the
federal programs we were administering
those Federal programs and there was
about another 600 a week in benefits
being paid out so you can add up those
uh those amounts can add up very quickly
um New Hampshire was was I would say
more successful than any other state in
detecting it prior to payment simply
because we went back to basics
um and we were we were scrupulously
analyzing each and every claim that came
through because we knew what the we knew
what the identity theft related markers
were it was just a matter of finding
them before payments issued tried to do
that with as little impact on
individuals that were rightfully filing
and needed those benefits to try not to
hold them up
um with the the criminals
um but it was just the the the staff
within that Fraud Unit looking at those
claims and shutting down those claims
before they paid and they were very very
very successful at that so you're gonna
there's been a lot with
hearings before Congress recently on the
the pandemic related fraud particularly
with the unemployment program but I
think New Hampshire could be held out as
an example of of how to properly
Safeguard trust fund dollars
um to really analyze those claims and to
be smart about
um how you're reviewing them prior to
payment because we were quite successful
um during the pandemic
just a couple of quick questions you
have a significant amount of money in
the trust fund are you allowed to
collect interest on that as a lot of its
federal dollars
so we the the trust fund earns quarterly
interest uh from the treasury Department
um so
um it does sit with treasury
um we have local accounts through which
we we draw funds from the uh account
that sits with the treasury we draw down
those funds to pay benefits we then
receive those tax payments and they go
through our local accounts and then go
to credit
um our trust fund but we do get
quarterly interest on that fund okay
so what about the unemployment insurance
tax rate that you mentioned earlier how
do we compare to say other states around
us as far as a percentage that's taken
from the employer
um so we compare very well against
um the rest of the Northeast
um we have the the lowest unemployment
insurance tax burden in the Northeast
and each state
um has slight differences in their
unemployment insurance tax
system so
um you know New Hampshire has a taxable
wage base of fourteen thousand dollars
meaning the employer pays out their rate
on the first fourteen thousand in annual
wages to each employee other states have
different taxable wage bases different
ways of setting those experience based
rates but when you do an Apples to
Apples comparison and you look at total
UI taxes paid compared against total
wages paid in each state New Hampshire
has the lowest UI tax burden in the
Northeast
and continuing to get lower the last uh
published comparison was prior to the
0.5 percent reduction that went into
effect for employers with the fourth
quarter of 2022 so those rates are are
continuing to come down
um so that the next publication that
will come out will have an even lower UI
tax burden for New Hampshire employers
compared to other states
and then the next one that comes out
will be even lower because we're
anticipating that the second quarter of
this year that will maintain a balance
that will allow those employers to get
that one percent uh tax rate reduction
so in very very important with those
reductions because with each reduction
you're reducing the cost of hiring
individuals so very important from uh
from a competition standpoint with
attracting businesses to New Hampshire
which we've been successful in doing
these past few years
so you kind of started to answer my
question so your contact with obviously
commissioner Caswell so that's something
when he's going out to attract business
he can use that figure to say look we
have this other benefit by okay great
yeah we and and commissioner Caswell
gets
um a whole bunch of us together
um every every month for for an update
on what's going on with the unemployment
insurance system both on the tax side
and the benefit side uh what we're
seeing in in the on the on the economic
and labor market information side as
well Brian gotlab is our director of
almie um Brian is uh uh quite the uh
data monster I guess you can look at him
he's just a data junkie and Brian
participates in those meetings but we we
talk
quite regularly with commissioner
Caswell and his team thanks uh
representative hatch represent Maguire
there did I see you yeah
so back to the fraud question uh do you
ever mail benefit checks out of state
yes we do okay why
so
um about 85 of individuals uh right now
elect to have their benefit payments
direct deposited into their account we
have about 15 percent
um within a few percentage points of
that that elect to have paper checks
issued to them but so in order to be
eligible for unemployment benefits in
New Hampshire you need to have worked in
New Hampshire and then had a qualifying
separation from a New Hampshire employer
so you could be a Massachusetts resident
of Vermont or Maine
and likewise New Hampshire residents
could be filing claims against
Massachusetts because they work in
Massachusetts so it's the state for in
which you worked that you collect
against
think that nobody would want to live
anywhere else yeah I don't understand so
so these people with fraud that from
other countries they're doing direct
deposit is that it they're
well they they weren't you need to be in
the contiguous U.S
um or Canada in order to be filing uh
for benefits and what was what was going
on with the the
uh ID theft related fraud was they would
they would have your name they would
have your social they probably had your
address they probably had your work
history
um but they were going to put a
different email down because they didn't
want the emails going to you
um and they were going to have a
different bank account and they wanted
to make sure to aggregate those bank
accounts so they weren't having to go to
a whole bunch of different banks and
they wanted those banks that were a bank
in name only and and kind of functioned
under the the banking uh regulatory
system kind of
um oversight and so you had patterns of
how the the the organizations
fraudulently using a identities
what they were doing for emails what
they were doing for for banks and the
trick was just staying ahead of of what
they were doing detecting it quickly
seeing those patterns and freezing those
those payments before they issued and
um
like like was mentioned before and
you'll hear more about if the
Congressional hearings continue There
were some of our larger States that had
hundreds of millions of dollars go out
before they realized that it was a
problem that how many benefit checks
they were sending to this this same bank
account or to these fictitious email
addresses okay
right unrelated question so the um the
Fourteen thousand dollar maximum that
people pay on how long has that been in
place
uh 2009
um
2009 there was a major reform in
response to the the Great Recession at
the time uh there were uh the taxable
wage base was increased from eight
thousand dollars they did that in a
graduated staggered way so it went first
to ten thousand following year to twelve
thousand the following year to 14 which
is where it has stayed so I think it hit
it got to 14
000 in 2012 is either 11 or 12 and it
stayed at that amount since that time
there are also other measures that got
put in place with that reform
um they created a a third table of tax
rates with that reform that were for
your more chronic negative rated
employers those employers that have
through seasonal patterns have large
layoff activity each year that were
overusing the unemployment program over
overusing compared to what they were
contributing
um so they they now as of that reform at
higher rates and individuals had a
waiting week implemented so prior to
that reform individuals did not have a
one-week waiting week as of that and
continuing to today individuals have a
waiting week for the first week of
Eligibility that they don't receive
benefits that was that waiting week was
waived during the pandemic but was put
back in in May of 21.
so if 427 is the normal Max that extra
six hundred dollars was a huge
incentive not to work yes and did the
feds also add things about
taking away this you're looking for work
and some of that those are the kinds of
requirements is
um so they they expanded eligibility
um with in terms of uh gig workers
self-employed traditionally
um it's only people in covered
employment so W-2 employment that are
eligible for unemployment benefits the
federal programs expanded that
eligibility they expanded that
eligibility to also include those that
didn't have enough earnings in their
base period to ordinarily qualify for
unemployment benefits so it was a much
larger group of people that was eligible
you had the additional 600 that went on
top of your 427 or whatever your weekly
benefit amount was that went from
April of 2020 through July of 2020 and
then there was a brief Hiatus to that
through a then uh Congress and the
President Clinton see eye to eye then
they came back with the additional three
hundred dollars that got added
following following after that so there
was a lot that was done to expand
eligibility to expand the amount of
benefits that that individuals were
receiving all of that
um came to an end in June of 21 in New
Hampshire some states some states went
to the end of the programs ended in the
federal program deadline was September
of 21 New Hampshire exited those
programs early earlier than other states
in June of 21 as an effort to try to get
more people back to work because we had
estimated through Brian gottlub's
analysis that about 70 percent of
individuals filing for unemployment
benefits When they were paying out the
additional 600 we're receiving more in
unemployment than they were for the work
that they had done prior to collecting
yeah well I am a part owner of a
restaurant it's impossible to hire
people during this period right I mean
it's crazy anyway thank you
are there any further questions uh not
seeing any thanks so much very good
presentation
you can't retire either you know
thank you yeah we'll take care